[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur SCP
journée passionnante consacrée au couple
franco-allemand nous sommes ensemble
jusqu'à 18h pour vivre en direct les
cérémonies d'anniversaire des 60 ans du
traité de l'Élysée le traité de
réconciliation entre la France et
l'Allemagne Emmanuel Macron Olaf scholls
la représentation nationale de nos deux
pays y consacrent leur journée vous le
verrez nous irons au Panthéon à Paris la
voici Valérie Brochard qui nous attend
sur place c'est là que sont attendus les
deux présidentes de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Bundestag et puis on ira
également à la Sorbonne ce sera le temps
fort de la journée où Marco pommier sera
en direct le grand amphithéâtre ou le
chancelier et le président Français
prendront la parole pour deux discours
important anniversaire percuté
évidemment par la guerre en Ukraine qui
selon certains rebats les cartes du
leadership en Europe avec moi pour en
parler 4 invités Nicole niesauto bonjour
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes la vice-présidente de l'Institut
Jacques Delore professeur titulaire de
la chair sur l'Union européenne au CNAM
et grande spécialiste de l'Allemagne
pays auquel vous avez consacré plusieurs
ouvrages bonjour Richard Verline et
merci d'être là figure régulière de la
Chaîne Parlementaire vous êtes le
correspondant France Europe du quotidien
suisse Blic à Paris bonjour Joseph
devêques et merci d'être avec nous
d'être crotte chroniqueur à la revue
allemande internationale politique
quarterly c'est bien ça et puis un
diplomate est avec nous diplomate
allemand à distance
Joachim biterlich merci d'être là ancien
conseiller européen et diplomatique du
chancelier et le mode call on va en
parler des loulcall forcément 60 ans
après le traité de l'Élysée on va partir
pour commencer tout de suite au Panthéon
Valérie Brochard les cérémonies
commencent comment se place des grands
hommes ce matin
et oui Myriam pour célébrer les 60 ans
du traité de l'Elysée pour célébrer
l'amitié entre la France et l'Allemagne
deux femmes deux présidentes viendront
dans quelques minutes s'avancer ici au
Panthéon la première et française c'est
Yaël brune pivelle à présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale la seconde est
tellement elle s'appelle barbelbass et
elle est à la tête du Bundes Instagram
alors c'est un premier rendez-vous au
très solennel dans cette journée de
célébration qui débute par le Panthéon
car vous le savez c'est ici que la
France abrite elle les grands hommes de
son histoire comme Jean Monnet ou André
Malraux mais dans quelques minutes les
deux présidents devront saluer la
mémoire d'une femme une icône pour nos
deux pays Simone Veil entrée au Panthéon
en juillet 2018 Simone Veil a été
ministre de la Santé sous la présidence
de Valérie Giscard d'Estaing elle fut à
l'origine de la célèbre loi veille qui
dépénalise l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse elle fut aussi la toute
première femme élue président du
Parlement européen c'était en 1979 tout
un symbole pour le couple
franco-allemand c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui se recueillir sur le tombeau
de Simone Veil c'est aussi se recueillir
devant l'histoire revenir sur ce qui est
assezlé les liens entre la France et
l'Allemagne c'est son nul doute
l'occasion pour les deux présidentes de
regarder le chemin parcouru et les défis
à venir merci beaucoup Valérie Brochard
avec André Lafont derrière la caméra je
vous propose pour pour commencer cette
journée qui va être forte en symbole de
revenir sur l'origine le traité de
l'Élysée pour la jeunesse qui nous
regarde pas un traité qui est familier
c'est pas un grand traité qui consacre
l'Union européenne qu'est-ce que le
traité de l'idée Nicole Lesotho
alors le traité de l'Elysée c'est une
proposition du général de Gaulle aux
chancelier Adenauer pour créer une union
de l'Europe une union des nations
européennes et dans la tête du général
de Gaulle ce traité avec pour but
d'essayer d'élaborer entre la France et
l'Allemagne une politique étrangère et
de sécurité et de défense commune et ce
traité d'ailleurs intervient il est
proposé à la signature aux Allemands une
semaine après que le général de Gaulle a
prononcé un très célèbre discours en
janvier 63 refusant la candidature
britannique à la CEE refusant de
commencer
refusons de participer à la force
multilatérale nucléaire que les
Américains proposaient pour essayer de
contrôler les ambitions nucléaires du
général de Gaulle et donc ce traité
porte la marque au départ de la vision
gaulienne de l'Europe c'est à dire une
Europe des nations sans intégration sans
droit de regard de l'Amérique or ce
traité commence par une crise
franco-allemande majeure puisque il est
signé par le chancelier Adenauer et le
jour de son où il doit être ratifié par
le Bund de Stein le Bundestag allemand
ajoute à ce traité un préambule qui dit
le contraire du traité c'est-à-dire que
l'Europe l'union politique de l'Europe
oui mais dans le cadre de la CEE parce
que de Gaulle détestait à l'époque la
défense commune oui mais dans le cadre
de l'OTAN et avec une perspective
d'adhésion des anglais donc objectif
inverse inverse totalement inverse de
Gaulle furieux d'ailleurs et rentrer à
Paris rentrer dans son bureau parce que
le a été signaléisé et le traité a été
mis dans un tiroir et donc c'est une
grave crise franco-allemande qui
commence avec ce traité de l'Elysée et
il faudra attendre Mitterrand école pour
réactiver le traité en 23 c'est pour ça
pour anticiper jusqu'à aujourd'hui moi
je crois que la crise franco-allemande
dont on parle tellement aujourd'hui la
crise elle est consubstantielle à la
relation franco-allemande mais on y
revient on Richard Berly quel malentendu
de départ faut quand même remettre les
choses dans leur contexte on est 20 ans
après la fin de la guerre de Gaulle à
denauer décide au fond de d'envoyer un
message de réconciliation c'est vraiment
un tournant dans l'histoire et en même
temps on se rend compte que on est
d'accord sur rien sur ce traité l'idée
de Gaulle c'est l'idée du pacte au fond
et c'est pour ça je pense que en France
on parle de couple franco-allemand
c'est-à-dire au fond c'est un contrat de
mariage en réalité c'est un contrat
d'union c'est un contrat de
fonctionnement commun de la France et de
l'Allemagne comme la dinicole sur la
base d'une vision qui est quand même
essentiellement française et donc c'est
toute l'ambiguïté à travers ce traité du
couple franco-allemande aujourd'hui ou
du tandem franco-allemand il est inspiré
d'une vision très française de ce que
doivent être ces relations il a été
ensuite nuancé par les Allemands au
point de déboucher sur une crise et
finalement maintenant il est venu un
pilier de la politique européenne et un
fondamental de un principe fondamental
au fond du fonctionnement de l'Union
d'une une manière parce qu'on lui prête
aujourd'hui des conséquences et un
impact qui vont bien au-delà de la
relation franco-allemande donc à la fois
impact essentiel mais un pacte dont on
voit bien que depuis le début il est
altéré secoué par des ambiguïtés qui
sont des ambiguïtés politiques mais
aussi de tempérament et de vision
Nicolas tribundi notamment depuis le
début cette question de la sécurité des
relations avec les États-Unis et
aujourd'hui évidemment avec la guerre en
Ukraine cette question de la défense
avec l'OTAN ou avec l'Europe ou avec les
deux elle est elle est fondamentale
Joseph devec pour bien comprendre
comment les Allemands voient ce couple
déjà il y a pas le mot de couple
apparemment en allemand on l'utilise pas
on n'est pas comme en France à vouloir
un mariage parfois contrarié parfois
heureux on est dans quelque chose de
beaucoup plus quoi de Tandem d'amitié
comment comment on le voit on en parle
de cette relation là
alors en Allemagne on utilise le terme
du moteur franco-allemand alors c'est
peut-être pas un couple mais si on sait
qu'elle est la relation intime qu'ils
ont avec leur voiture c'est peut-être
très facile que le couple si on parle de
moteur c'est essentiel à la voiture ce
qui fait
c'est le cœur de l'industrie allemande
alors il donne une importance aussi à la
France et ils utilisent peut-être des
autres termes pour ça mais ce qui est
intéressant avec le traité d'Elysée et
1963 c'est que le couple franco-allemand
il prédate ce traité c'est pas avec le
traité de 63 a commencé en 63 il a pas
du tout commencé en 63 il commence déjà
beaucoup avant et c'est c'est en réalité
63 c'est l'année où ardena work quitte
le pouvoir aussi si vous voulez le
traiter d'Elysée c'est un des derniers
actes qu'il fait encore et dans une
perspective visée en française comme
Richard a dit voilà ou comme vous l'avez
dit c'était l'idée quand on crée cet axe
pas de menthe qui est le cœur de
l'Europe et après qui se trace un avenir
un destin séparément vous dites axe
franco-allemand le cœur de l'Europe en
1950 il y a il y a pas encore le
Royaume-Uni c'est bien ça donc d'entrée
de jeu dès la création de l'Union
européenne avant même se traiter de
réconciliation c'est au tour de ce
couple ou de ce tandem de ce moteur pour
des raisons quoi historiques
géographiques qu'il faut avancer ou
simplement économique alors il faut voir
qu'avant le traité de l'Elysée la
relation franco-allemande a continué
d'être conflictuelle après la guerre ça
n'a pas eu une réelle conciliation
immédiate en particulier quand à partir
de 1950 c'est à dire la guerre de Corée
là-bas en Asie les Américains décident
que peut-être on peut voir la même chose
sur le continent européen de la part de
l'URSS et qu'il faut donc réarmer
l'Allemagne les Français ont été le pays
qui ont le plus freiné des quatre frères
pour le réarmement allemand entre en
1950 et 1954 et les Français c'est là où
on a inventé cette histoire de la CED la
Communauté européenne de défense pour
mettre une armée allemande dans une
configuration européenne qui
contrôlerait complètement l'armée
allemande et finalement malgré tout ce
projet qui était le projet de CED de
René Pleven
malgré cela le Parlement français 4 ans
après en 54 donc va refuser de ratifier
le traité de la CED avec le slogan en
réarme l'Allemagne et on désarme la
France donc la relation était encore
très conflictuelle en 54 et sont les
Américains qui ont dit ok ça suffit
maintenant on va mettre tout le monde
d'accord on met tout le monde dans
l'OTAN et en 54 les Allemands seront
réarmés mais dans le cadre Atlantique en
rentrant avec l'Italie dans l'OTAN et
donc ça n'est que petit à petit entre 54
et 63 construite les relations vont
s'apaiser entre la France et l'Allemagne
mais au départ ça pas été du tout
évident Joachim biterleiche vous qui
avez travaillé avec Helmut cool au fond
est-ce que c'est lui le chanceux lui
colle et le président Mitterrand qui
peuvent au fond être les
héritiers du mot de réconciliation
véritablement
ah malheureusement la liaison n'est pas
bonne alors je m'adresse à celle la
question à vous Richard
le retour en grâce du traité de l'Elysée
et de sa symbolique politique elle est
effectivement le couple mitterrancool et
d'ailleurs peut-être pour les mêmes
raisons que le couple originel ou que le
moteur originel de Gaulle Adenauer chez
De Gaulle il y a quand même une
obsession qui est l'obsession de la
puissance française alors la puissance
française elle a été pendant la
Quatrième République quand même
sérieusement ébranlée pendant la digue
par la décolonisation ensuite il y a eu
la crise de Suez en 56 ou là la France a
bien vu avec le Royaume-Uni la
difficulté qu'elle avait d'imposer c'est
vu sur le monde et donc de Gaulle se
tourne vers l'Allemagne et je crois que
c'est aussi ça ce que fait Mitterrand
c'est à dire qu'il va se tourner vers
l'Allemagne en disant nous devons
avancer ensemble dans les deux cas vous
noterez que l'impulsion il faut bien le
dire elle est quand même française à
chaque fois c'est la France qui se
tourne vers l'Allemagne en disant nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que d'avancer
ensemble et la cool qui est à
l'initiative donc oui le couple
mitterrancole est absolument décisif
mais c'est toujours de Paris que vient
la demande alors que vous le voyez sur
ces images la Sorbonne commence à se
remplir beaucoup d'élus des deux côtés
du rein des députés français des députés
allemands qui ont fait le voyage mais
aussi des étudiants qui vont écouter
tout à l'heure le chancelier allemand le
président français dans ce grand
amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne si
symbolique sous la houlette des statuts
de de Sorbon de Descartes mais aussi
mais aussi de Pascal enfin on écoutera
tout ça voilà le décor est évidemment
majestueux et symbolique on pense
évidemment au discours de la Sorbonne de
d'Emmanuel Macron de 2017 on verra si on
peut tresser des ponts entre entre ces
deux discours tout à l'heure vers 11h
Joseph devec c'est la France qui a
toujours été en avant du moteur
on peut dire ça comme ça et c'est
presque toujours la France qui a eu les
idées et qui a fait les propositions
la France elle a toujours vu aussi cet
axe franco-allemande comme voilà comme
cette force au sein de l'Union
européenne qui peut faire avancer
l'Europe et elle a toujours vu aussi
l'Europe comme un outil pour pour faire
sa politique pour se réinstaurer pour
pour quelle raison pour des raisons
d'intérêt parce que c'était la première
c'est toujours d'ailleurs la première
économie l'Allemagne de l'Europe et donc
on peut pas faire sans elle et on veut
garder la voix de la France qui en gros
à ce poids diplomatique dans le monde
alors que c'est plutôt l'économie après
la guerre qui a souhaité jouer
l'Allemagne ou pour des raisons purement
européennes on va dire collective
d'union
je pense pour les deux pour les deux
raisons mais je pense il faut il faut
voir un peu d'où vient l'Allemagne quand
elle sort de la deuxième guerre mondiale
l'objectif principal de Harden hour
c'est de réhabiliter d'une certaine
manière l'Allemagne et la France et la
clé pour l'Allemagne pour réintégrer le
concert des nations et d'être accepté et
alors le traité d'Elysée de 63 pour
adonawa si vous voulez c'est le climat
qui qui démontre que sa politique de
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
depuis 45 de réintégrer l'Allemagne dans
le concert des nations et de la faire
accepter comme une comme un pays qui
existe qui a le droit d'exister et qui
parle et qui a une voix c'est ça ce que
adona voulait vraiment avec ce traité et
c'est ça et là il y a un peu le
malentendu l'Allemagne elle cherche la
relation avec la France parce qu'elle
sait la France et la clé pour pour se
réintégrer en Europe alors que la France
est dit oui il faut se réconcilier avec
l'Allemagne mais aussi est toujours
tourné vers parce qu'elle dit c'est on
construit on construisant avec
l'Allemagne que l'Europe peser de
nouveau peut parler à un niveau d'égal à
Washington à Moscou alors les
motivations ils sont pas exactement les
mêmes et jusqu'au jour aujourd'hui le
franco-allemand c'est un peu une dispute
entre ces deux positions pour arriver
justement à la relation aujourd'hui au
fond c'est parce qu'il y a toujours eu
des différents voire des crises que ce
couple est si important parce qu'il pèse
plus que les autres en Europe alors
d'abord il pèse beaucoup plus oui
aujourd'hui l'Allemagne c'est la
première économie de l'Union la France
la deuxième l'Allemagne est le premier
contributeur net au budget de l'Union de
France le deuxième et ensemble la France
et l'Allemagne c'est un tiers un peu
plus d'un tiers de la population de
l'Union européenne on semble on fait
quand même 150 millions d'habitants et
en matière militaire on est à 85%
ensemble de la R&D militaire européenne
donc moi je veux bien qu'un État égal 1
mais il y a aussi une question d'un
poids politique mais
oui moi je pense que l'importance de ce
tandem ou de ce moteur franco-allemand
vient du fait que objectivement ce sont
les pays les plus différents de l'Union
européenne alors on a peut-être pas le
temps là de voir mais la France d'un
pays militaire obsédé de la puissance la
France l'Allemagne était un pays
pacifique par le commerce la France est
un pays
on peut dire
Jacobins l'Allemagne est un pays fédéral
qui partage son pouvoir et l'Allemagne
est un pays de compromis tout se décide
au Parlement de vues de brutalité de
position c'est dans tous les les
séparres la France est un pays du Sud un
peu anaxis avec les règles économiques
et monétaire en France d'un pays
l'Allemagne d'un pays protestant austère
etc bon bref tous les opposes et donc
quand la France et l'Allemagne sont
d'accord sur quelque chose ont réussi sa
trouver un compromis sur quelque chose
alors on est à peu près sûr que les
autres pays européens vont suivre c'est
pour ça c'est un moteur c'est parce que
on est très différent dans l'un de
l'autre et tant mieux parce que c'est ça
qui fait la qualité du moteur et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui en dépit des
divergences que l'on a toujours on va y
venir pas une option de est-ce que je
peux commenter un tout petit peu ce qui
a écrit tout à l'heure par Joseph devait
on accuse toujours les Français d'avoir
une vision instrumentalisme de l'Europe
c'est à dire l'Europe ça leur sert à
magnifier multiplier démultiplier la
puissance française alors comme si des
autres Européens avaient une vision
européenne et la France une vision très
nationale mais vous l'avez bien dit les
Allemands c'est exactement pareil ils
ont eu dès le départ une vision
instrumentaliste de l'Europe c'était
d'utiliser l'Europe pour refaire une
puissance allemande acceptable
acceptable par les partenaires
américains sur le plan militaire
acceptable par les autres pays européens
parce que l'Allemagne ne faisait plus
peur et donc c'est quand même toujours
un peu agaçant d'entendre nos
partenaires européens dire que la France
utilise l'Europe à son avantage comme si
ne le faisait pas mais les autres font
exactement voilà qui est rétabli je vous
donne la parole dans un instant Richard
Berlio va tout de suite prendre la
direction de la Sorbonne nous attend
Marco pommier Marco le chef de l'État et
chancelier devrait arriver aux alentours
de de 11h quelle est l'atmosphère devant
l'entrée de la grande université
française et à quoi peut-on s'attendre
tout à l'heure
et bien écoutez Myriam ici pour l'heure
c'est assez calme les parlementaires
français et allemands arrivent
progressivement à la Sorbonne on attend
entre 200 et 300 parlementaires français
allemands quand même pour l'heure en
fait c'est la deuxième étape de cette
matinée hein Myriam elle les allocutions
le chancelier allemand puis d'Emmanuel
Macron deux discours qui seront
prononcés juste après ceux de Yaël
LeBron Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et de barbelbass
présidente du bootenstag allemand prise
de parole prévue aux alentours de 11h15
nous dit-on des discours prononcés dans
le grand tamphithéâtre de la Sorbonne
dans un décor majestueux ça se passera
juste derrière moi ce sera tout à
l'heure vers 11h15 merci Marco et alors
que vous le voyez en direct sur LCP la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
celle du Bundes stack qui vont entrer
dans le panthéon le Panthéon vous le
savez elles doivent se recueillir sur la
tombe de Simone Veil première femme à
présider le européen on les entendra
tout à l'heure moment de symbole des
images aussi les femmes à l'honneur
aussi pour célébrer cet anniversaire 60
ans après la signature du traité de
l'Élysée Richard Verly pour reprendre la
discussion sur France Allemagne qui est
moteur de qui mais d'abord le couple et
les moteurs ils ont une similitude c'est
qu'il vieillissent et que lorsque le
couple vieillit les conjoints n'ont pas
toujours les mêmes les mêmes envies les
mêmes omissions les mêmes ambitions et
lorsqu’un moteur vieilli c'est encore
plus problématique parce que la voiture
a des difficultés et donc il faut bien
voir que 60 ans c'est assez long et donc
la situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui elle est évidemment le
produit de l'histoire vous avez rappelé
Myriam en parlant de Simone Veil
évidemment on pense aussi à la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et du personnel que fut
celle de Simone Veil il y a aussi chez
De Gaulle avec ce traité l'ambition de
tourner définitivement la page de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale y compris chez
De Gaulle rappelons qu'en 63 il est à
l'apogée de son pouvoir politique il est
revenu au pouvoir en 19 58 à partir de
1963 ça va lentement se gâter pour aller
jusqu'à 1968 et de Gaulle il a aussi
cette idée que c'est une nouvelle
Allemagne qui doit arriver sur la scène
internationale et que la France doit et
a pour mission de faire accoucher cette
nouvelle Allemagne donc je crois que il
y a vraiment un message d'espoir
d'avenir encore une fois très français
après la difficulté c'est que la vraie
histoire celle des événements à petit à
petit repris son cours de Gaulle est
parti il y a eu en Allemagne une période
très difficile on oublie qui a été celle
des années 70 très compliqué avec une
contestation très forte avec le retour
très très fort de la contestation sur la
des nazification qui n'avait pas eu lieu
vous vous souvenez donc ce traité de
l'Elysée il a toujours été au fond
otage des personnes et des circonstances
donc c'est pas étonnant que ce soit un
duo Mitterrand école qui les ressuscité
alors que vous le voyez les présidentes
de l'Assemblée nationale il y a El Brown
Pivet et du bundestack Barbe Bleue sont
dans maintenant la nef du Panthéon et
ils vont ils vont bientôt se rendre sur
la tombe de la grande femme puisque on
dit aux grands hommes la nation
reconnaissance grande femme Simone Veil
et vous pourrez suivre ça en direct
Joseph deck je voudrais qu'on aborde la
contemporanité de la relation
aujourd'hui sur une échelle de 1 à 10
vous que diriez-vous 17 ans le maximum
de l'Entente comment va la relation
franco-allemande entre Paris et Berlin
on peut toujours voir le verre à moitié
plein à moitié vide mais en ce moment je
pense on est plutôt à 4
est-ce qu'on peut parler de crise
c'est pas beaucoup regarde c'est pas
beaucoup on peut parler de crise dans le
sens que oui c'est assez inédit qu'on a
par exemple un conseil des ministres
franco-allemand qui est reporté ils
disent reporter mais pour moi c'était en
octobre dernier à Fontainebleau il n'a
pas eu lieu et c'était rarissime et
c'est très rare qu'on voit le président
et le chancelier publiquement être
tellement en désaccord il y a quand même
par exemple ça commence avec le grand
discours de Olaf Scholtz à Prague son
discours sur l'Europe ou shots ne
mentionne pas le couple franco-allemand
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
nouveau mer qu'elle a toujours mentionné
elle a toujours parlé ce langage du
franco-allemand après on peut en dire
dans les actes peut-être la pas toujours
été la plus grande franco allemande
surtout au début de ce de ces mandats
mais elle a toujours fait ce jeu elle a
joué ce jeu et ne le fait pas après il y
a cette épisode où à Macron propose un
shot d’aller ensemble à Pékin
avoir comme un nucléose une politique
européenne envers la Chine
refuse
après il y a Macron qui qui renvoie la
balle d'une certaine manière qui dit que
l'Allemagne est complètement isolé à
Bruxelles
sur la question de
le mot d'égoïsme mais on entend ce mot
derrière la l'isolement allemand et
après il y a toujours eu des crises
l'histoire de l'Europe c'est l'Europe de
des crises l'histoire du couple
franco-allemand c'est l'histoire des
crises mais cette fois-ci entre la
question de la défense la guerre en
Ukraine la politique énergétique avec la
dépendance au gaz russe des Allemands la
question commerciale aussi et
industrielle vis-à-vis des Américains le
protectionnisme de Joe Biden vous diriez
que elle est grave cette crise ou pas
moi je pense que la crise elle est pas
fondamentale il faut dire d'abord un
truc que il y a 12 mois où il y a 14
mois la relation franco-allemande elle
était à une apogée et il y a quand même
c'est comme il y a deux ou trois ans
qu'on a décidé de mettre en place fond
de sauvetage européen de 750 milliards
et il faut vraiment dire que c'était un
pas gigantesque de l'Allemagne de faire
ça de décider de s'endetter en tant que
européen c'est vraiment c'était un tabou
politique total et l'Allemagne était
prêt à le faire et d'une certaine
manière je pense quelques fois en France
il faut un peu plus reconnaître aussi
que l'Allemagne a fait des groupes pour
pour construire cette repense ensemble
ce qui était difficile mais aujourd'hui
oui je pense il y a une espèce de crise
cette journée elle tombe très bien parce
que force tout le monde de revenir
ensemble on verra d'ailleurs si au-delà
des symboles au-delà des sourires et des
images des annonces sont faites on parle
d'impact il y a une tribune qui a été
signée dans le Journal du dimanche entre
le chancelier allemand et le président
président français ce matin Joachim
biterly je vais réessayer vers vous si
la connexion est meilleure toujours sur
cette relation aujourd'hui entre Paris
et Berlin quelle est votre regard est-ce
que vous êtes plutôt optimiste à
relativiser les tensions ou au contraire
vous les assumez
il faut les assumer
Joseph a peut-être raison de dire ces
quatre sur 10 actuellement la note moi
je dirais 5 sur 10 pas plus parce que
évidemment il s'agit d'une crise mais on
a toujours eu les crises entre la France
et l'Allemagne nous avons des intérêts
divergents des intérêts nationaux
divergents et surtout en crise il a un
phénomène toujours observé c'est chacun
regarde d'abord son nombril c'est à dire
la France regarde l'Allemagne et se
regarde et par exemple le reproche son
discours de choses à Prague moi je
trouve un petit peu ridicule parce que
bien les Allemands auraient pu informer
les Français mais de l'autre côté il
fallait comprendre les circonstances
l'environnement ce discours ne voyage à
Pékin en coréen discuter longuement bien
sûr dire que les Allemands étaient
isolés à Bruxelles et je dirais
c'était autant isolé que l'Allemagne et
c'est vrai mais regardez le Fond
Européen Joseph a eu raison de le
mentionner et c'est un pas gigantesque
en avant mais que Paris a faire une fois
les Allemands lancés et Paris a essayé
le lendemain de demander aux Allemands
on va doubler se font
si aujourd'hui ou importantes entre
Paris et Berlin c'est tout simplement
pas parce que la guerre ont-ukraine
déstabilise très très profondément
l'Allemagne dans dans tous ses choix
fondamentaux est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça
pardonnez-moi bien sûr c'est Joachim
biteri je m'adresse à vous pardonnez-moi
la guerre en Ukraine a déstabilisé
énormément l'Allemagne et actuellement
c'est au lasals qui gouvernement
l'Allemagne contre la majorité au sein
du bonus stock ça il faut pas oublier
contre la majorité au sein de son parti
et contre la majorité au sein du
partenaire des Verts évidemment ça
déstabilise mais jusqu'à maintenant je
vous dis franchement il est allé au
maximum où il pouvait aller jusqu'à
présent et évidemment
en réalité on est encore au début de la
sainte elle n'est pas encore
durable c'est le c'est le changement
d'époque après le discours de la Scholtz
qui décide de se voilà de réengager
l'Allemagne vers une défense puissante
pardonnez-moi je vais vous interrompre
parce que voilà on va regarder commenter
de ces images en direct ça y est les
deux présidentes allemandes du bodenstag
et française de l'Assemblée nationale
vont déposer donc vous le voyez une
gerbe
en souvenir
et à la mémoire de Simone Veil
on va regarder ces images ensemble
signer André Lafont en direct sur LCP
et ce moment de recueillement
particulier les femmes à l'honneur de
femmes à la tête de leur parlement
respectif
S qui en célèbre une troisième ou
combien
historiques on n'est pas n'importe où
le Panthéon ça dit aussi quelque chose
oui c'est le l'hommage de la France au
grands hommes qui ont fait la France et
l'Europe
et là je crois que dans cette voie voilà
René Cassin des grands-pères moulins
grand-père et aussi Simone Veil mais
André Malraux
pardonnez-moi je vois Jean Monnet
évidemment
tous les fondateurs d'une certaine façon
ce mythe européen en tout cas dans
l'imaginaire des français Joseph de Vex
Simone Veil en Allemagne et connu
elle est oui elle est connue elle est
pas cette personne
vraiment connue universellement comme
elle est en France d'ailleurs il y a
jusqu'à un film qui est sorti dans le
cinéma sur Simone Veil elle est pas une
connue comme ça mais oui elle est une
personne forte avec son histoire
personnelle qui avait décidé aussi qu'il
fallait attendre la main aux Allemands
que madéna avoir l'a fait et
jusque par sa vie personnelle elle est
connue en Allemagne juste après la
guerre elle a suivi Antoine veille son
mari ce qui n'était pas un choix un
choix facile
Simone Veil c'est aussi la figure de la
réconciliation
il y a LeBron Pivet à une histoire
personnelle
une partie de sa famille
a connu la Shoah la présidente la
présidente allemande du bonenstad là
aussi choisi c'est pas rien aujourd'hui
d'avoir ces femmes devant ce tombeau là
c'est évidemment très important est très
symbolique la question que je me pose en
regardant ces images je ne sais pas si
la présidente du Bundestag est
francophone et s'il Yaël brande PV et
germanophone mais mine de rien ça a
beaucoup d'importance parce que
rappelons-nous que de Gaulle comprenait
l'allemand et que Adenauer parler
français et donc vous aviez quand même
une époque où les deux je dirais les
deux pays étaient conduits par des
personnalités qui bien sûr avec les
épreuves des guerres mais qui avait le
destin franco-allemand en tête qui était
habité par un destin franco-allemand et
qu'il l'avait vécu pour de Gaulle et
pour adénor dans le dans les pires des
épreuves Première et Seconde Guerre
mondiale là ma question que je me pose
en voyant ces images c'est est-ce que
ces deux femmes c'est très symbolique
mais qu'est-ce qu'elles ont en commun et
j'aimerais le savoir on aimerait bien
sûr écouter ce qui est en train
de s'exprimer on va les journalistes
qu'est-ce que les ceux les dirigeants
qui sont aujourd'hui côte à côte
qu'ont-ils en commun alors ça ça pose la
question de le couple la bonne santé du
couple franco-allemand mesure-t-il aux
dirigeants de la France et de
l'Allemagne ou pas alors oui je crois
parce que on a beaucoup parlé de de
gauladenauer et de mitterrancool mais il
y a eu d'autres coupes très importants
franco-allemand dans l'histoire de
l'Europe il y a eu d'abord Mitterrand
Schmitt pardon Giscard Helmut
qui alors n'ont pas signé traité mais
qui ont été à l'origine lointaines de
l'euro puisque c'est eux qui ont inventé
le serpent monétaire européen c'est eux
qui ont inventé la coopération politique
européenne c'est à dire le début de
cette Europe politique de politique
étrangère c'est quand même Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing et Schmidt et ensuite
après mitterrancole on a eu chirax
rudder qui ont qui sont en des très bien
qui ont été à l'origine du seul acte
indépendantiste si je puis dire de
l'Allemagne au sein de l'Alliance
puisque ce sont eux qui ont ce sont
élevés contre la volonté américaine
d'intervenir militairement ce sont les
pays qui ont dit non à l'intervention
américaine en Irak et pour l'Allemagne
c'était une première dans l'histoire de
ces relations avec les États-Unis et ce
couple schreuilder Chirac a eu une
importance tout à fait considérable dans
l'affirmation d'Europe parfois
d'ailleurs un peu passé sous silence
parce qu'après il y a le fameux mercosi
voilà alors après il y a Madame Merkel
et Monsieur Sarkozy là je crois qu'il y
avait aucun atome crochet entre les deux
la différence des prétendants coups je
crois qu'il y avait vraiment un problème
de personnalité mais ils ont quand même
porté l'Europe de façon magistrale en
particulier pendant la crise de 2008
enfin la crise économique de 2008 qui
arrive en Europe en 2010-2011 et ils ont
été à l'origine ensemble du G20 de la
comment dire de la montée en puissance
de la défense européenne à l'époque donc
un couple qui a été également très utile
et après on arrive effectivement à
Hollande Merkel Hollande les accords
au départ et puis ensuite ils se
rencontrent vraiment mais au nom de
Merkel je dois dire que c'est quand même
le couple qui a été je crois le moins
productif il s'entendait bien mais en
termes de réalisation je crois que c'est
quand même le couple qui a été le moins
productif dans l'intégration européenne
le couple Macron Merkel a été très
productif on a dit tout à l'heure
pendant la crise du covid ou là je
rappelle c'est les Français qui
proposent cette endettement commun
Madame Merkel dit non non non elle sait
pas ralliée de de très volontiers il y a
une vraie crise franco-allemande à tel
point que
Jacques Delors du haut de ses 92 ans à
l'époque a pris sa plume pour faire une
dépêche à l'AFP en disant attention le
repas s'effondrer si vous ne vous mettez
pas d'accord et l'accord franco-aluant a
eu lieu en mai
2020 donc un couple là aussi voilà je
voudrais dire ça la personnalité est
importante et ce qui est fascinant dans
l'histoire de l'Europe et donc
franco-allemand c'est que
systématiquement quel que soit leur
animosité leur divergence ils arrivent
quand même à faire avancer le j'allais
pas dire le spinblique mais
on comprend très bien ce que vous voulez
dire joachimie puisque on a retrouvé la
liaison que pensez-vous du couple
franco-allemand actuel qui apprend à se
connaître Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
la situation de la chose à Berlin
incomparable à celle de d'Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron dans sa deuxième
période chose dans sa première
gouverne une nouvelle coalition gouverne
d'un gouvernement qui n'a jamais été
ensemble comme ça
se trouve face à une situation
bouleversante la guerre la guerre en
Ukraine et il doit changer la politique
contrairement à la volonté de la
majorité des parties qui portent cette
coalition
donc les situations extrêmement
difficiles deux ce sont vous savez
penser à un muchmid il me fait penser
aux jeunes et muchmidt c'est un
labourgeois très pragmatique
ouvert c'est pas un communicateur du
tout
il est dans sa première période
chers français ayez un petit peu de
patience avec
alors que vous voyez que elle est de
présidente se préparent pour une
première intervention après cette étape
au Panthéon aujourd'hui on va vous la
faire vivre évidemment en direct Joseph
devait la coalition en Allemagne est
particulière à trois d'habitude c'est
deux les partenaires là c'est 3 alors
pardonnez-moi priorité au direct on va
écouter via LeBron Pivet qui va répondre
aux questions de Valérie Brochard en
direct sur LCP bonjour mesdames alors en
1979 Simone Veil formulait un vœu celui
des prouvé le sentiment d'avoir fait
progresser l'Europe est-ce que c'est ce
qui guide aujourd'hui votre journée et
cette rencontre ce qui guide notre
journée c'est de savoir et de se
remémorer d'où l'on vient pour savoir où
on va aller et c'est vrai que nous
avions exprimé le souhait toutes les
deux en tant que président du bundeslag
et de l'Assemblée nationale de pouvoir
marquer cette journée dans cette avec
cette commémoration et cet hommage à
celle qui fut la première présidente du
Parlement européen et celle qui a porté
plus que tout ses combats pour justement
l'amitié franco-allemande et pour une
paix durable en Europe donc finalement
nous ne pouvions pas commencer cette
journée sans lui rendre un hommage
marqué et appuyé et sans nous inscrire
profondément dans ses pas et pour vous
Barbel base que représente Simone Veil
une
femme visionnaire et une grande
européenne
personnel En tant qu'amende c'était je
ressens une grande une grande gratitude
de commémorer Simone Veil aujourd'hui
elle avait étendu la main aux Allemands
et rappelons-le jeune survivant de
l'holocaus elle a perdu sa mère son père
et son frère et c'est donc une profonde
gratitude aujourd'hui pour moi d'être
ici et de rencontrer un grand honneur de
rencontrer ces deux fils et je remercie
beaucoup madame la Présidente de l'avoir
rendu possible est-ce que est-ce que le
tandem franco-allemand se relance
aujourd'hui
ecoutez moi j'ai pas le sentiment qu'il
ait été en panne ce qui est certain
c'est que depuis plusieurs mois les
rencontres sont extrêmement fréquentes
je suis allée à deux reprises à Berlin
et je crois que il est très important
vous savez lorsqu'il y a lorsqu'on parle
de Tandem on parle aussi d'hommes et de
femmes pour pouvoir justement mener ce
cette action commune et il est certain
qu'avec berbel avec le Conseil des
ministres franco-allemand aujourd'hui
qui se tient Paris avec l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande nous
multiplions à tous les échelons les
liens les actions et les convergences
entre nos deux pays et je crois que plus
que jamais c'est essentiel dans le monde
qui est le nôtre et dans lequel nous
voyons qu'il y a des menaces qui pèsent
sur nos valeurs sur nos démocraties et
donc plus que jamais le couple
franco-allemand uni dans une Europe unie
et vitale pour notre avenir et notre
avenir à tous est-ce qu'il repart
aujourd'hui ce qui se relance
aujourd'hui ce couple franco-allemand
[Musique]
un excellent tandem il est important que
l'amitié franco-allemande nous nous
donnions un nouveau souffle
nos deux pays font face à de nombreux
défis et nos deux pays sont forts nous
voulons avancer ensemble donc malgré nos
différences faire avancer l'Europe
ensemble merci beaucoup prochaine étape
la Sorbonne
et Merci à VOUS belle
on va écouter à nouveau
NON MERCI MERCI BEAUCOUP Richard Berli
un premier un premier commentaire
volonté de faire avancer ce couple il ne
pouvait pas en être autrement
aujourd'hui non et c'est le début de la
journée donc on est on est d'une part on
sort du Panthéon on sort de du
recueillement devant la tombe de Simone
Veil et on est au début de cette journée
donc il faut pas oublier que le moment
clé c'est quand même les deux discours
du chancelier allemand d'une part et du
président de la République d'autre part
c'est là qu'on aura ou pas mais on aura
sans doute une vision commune il y a un
mot dans ce qu'a dit j'étais très
important c'est la patience c'est vrai
que si on regarde depuis le début
l'impatience est toujours plutôt du côté
français y compris dans le tempérament
on a cité Nicolas Sarkozy qui était un
impatient notoire et moi pour avoir été
correspondre à Bruxelles à cette époque
on savait quand j'ai la mer qu'elle
était très agacée de cette impatience
permanente
le président français de nos
institutions et plus puissants que la
Chancel IRL prend son temps parce que le
Bundestag doit tout voter oui alors il y
a absolument l'aspect institutionnel
mais il y a quand même aussi le côté du
tempérament le fait que en France on est
dans une culture politique extrêmement
verticale le président décide et donc
les les autres exécutent en quelque
sorte c'est pas le cas en Allemagne mais
je reviens sur cette impatience elle est
aussi aujourd'hui du côté d'Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron est assez
impatient donc oui la patience va être
un véritable défi mais pour qu'il la
patience fonctionne il faut qu'il y ait
des garanties et de la confiance et au
fond c'est la confiance qui à mon avis
aujourd'hui le mot clé alors justement
on va en parler de cette confiance alors
que vous le voyez les images en direct
de la Sorbonne avec l'arrivée de
nombreux membres du gouvernement Papen
DIY pour l'éducation Gérald Darmanin
c'est Isabelle Rome à l'antenne qui
arrive on a vu également Eric
Dupond-Moretti ou encore François Braun
le ministre de la Santé le gouvernement
au grand complet et cette grande
amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne si
symbolique sous la houlette de Pascal
sous la houlette de Descartes de Joseph
de Sorbon qui se remplit progressivement
avec aussi la jeunesse et vous le voyez
à l'image les deux présidentes de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Bundes qui
vont maintenant se rendre directement à
la Sorbonne à la fois pour prendre la
parole et bien sûr pour écouter les
discours attendus du chancelier Scholtz
et du président Macron aux alentours de
11h15 en direct sur LCP bien sûr Joseph
devec
le processus de décision est très
différent les temporalités sont très
différentes et ça peut agacer parfois
Paris on a vu avec avec Nicolas Sarkozy
et avec Angela Merkel pour revenir sur
aujourd'hui
on va nous dire que il faut continuer
d'avancer on a compris qu'en gros on n'a
pas le choix si on tient à simplement on
a du mal à voir quel serait les points
d'avancer concrets aujourd'hui à quoi
peut-on s'attendre sur quoi le moteur
peut-il repartir
je pense il y a une grande convergence
de vue sur sur le thème de souveraineté
européenne et surtout sa dimension
économique c'est-à-dire que depuis
quelques années depuis 4-5 ans
l'Allemagne est en train de réaliser que
ce modèle économique a de plus en plus
de défis d'un côté il y a la Chine la
Chine n'est plus le grand marché
d'exportation qui tire la croissance
allemande en fait les exportations de
l'Allemagne vers la Chine stagne dans
beaucoup de secteurs depuis 2014 15 2016
mais la dépendance reste forte quand
même la dépendance reste très forte la
Chine et le premier commercial de
l'Allemagne mais c'est plus la Chine qui
tire la croissance c'est plus de la
Chine que
en faveur d'une politique industrielle
commune sur des grands projets on parle
des microprocesseurs des batteries
électriques en Europe et oui parce que
l'équivalent du Medef allemand déjà
depuis 2018-2019 dit on doit avoir un
changement une politique commerciale
aussi et il y a la Chine mais il y a
d'autres raisons aussi qui poussent un
peu l'Allemagne plus vers un système
économique qui est plus proche de l'état
avec un état plus volontariste plus
d'investissement et à plus un modèle
économique qui est tiré sur l'innovation
et la croissance de la productivité
alors que seulement sur les exportations
et je pense l'Allemagne est en train de
réaliser que son économie doit être
rendu plus résiliente et que du coup à
l'avenir l'état
une économie plus résiliente plus
résiliente ça veut dire plus dépendre en
elle-même moins dépendant d'autres voilà
dans de mon énergétiques de la Russie
voilà pour la croissance pour la Chine
et là il y a un vrai changement qui se
fait pas seulement depuis le
commencement de la guerre de crâne mais
on est dans un processus long qui se
fait depuis quatre cinq ans déjà et je
pense la pensée économique allemande
elle est en train d'aller vers plus vers
une pensée française et je pense si on
va voir des avancées aujourd'hui dans
ces discours je pensais sur ce thème là
qu'on souveraineté économique c'est le
c'est le sujet je vous donne la parole
Nicole mais on va rejoindre Marco
pommier Marco qui est à la Sorbonne
quelle est l'ambiance autour de vous
l'amphithéâtre se remplit manifestement
oui
la garderie républicaine est prête on
attend l'arrivée de Marvel bass et de
Yelle Brown privé la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui sera accueilli
dans quelques minutes par le recteur de
Paris et le chancelier des universités
d'Île-de-France place ensuite aux
arrivées d'Emmanuel Macron et de la
Scholtz le chancelier allemand 4
personnalités qui prendront donc la
parole dans le grand amphithéâtre de la
Sorbonne dans ce décor majestueux devant
200 à 300 parlementaires franco-allemand
français et allemand plutôt les
ministres également des deux
gouvernements respectifs sont présents
ce que je peux vous dire aussi Myriam
c'est que cette cérémonie officielle est
bien elle se refermera par les hymnes
européens français et allemands trois
hymnes chantées acapella par le cœur de
la garderie républicaine merci Marco et
n'hésitez pas à nous faire signe dès que
les présidentes arrivent et bien sûr les
chefs d'État chancelier Nicole misotto
c'est vraiment sur ce sujet là qu'on
attend aujourd'hui les dirigeants
allemands et français la question
commerciale la question économique c'est
une des questions importantes mais moi
je crois qu'avant de savoir comment on
peut renoncer le couple franco-allemand
il faut quand même savoir
ce que chacun peut faire or on est
aujourd'hui dans une état dans une
situation de crise non pas de couple
franco-allemand mais de crise européenne
de crise stratégique économique
environnementale écologique nous les
choses alors moi je cette crise elle
touche l'Allemagne elle touche l'Europe
en toute entière elle touche si on
regarde qui est le plus affecté par les
l'ensemble des crises aujourd'hui en
Europe c'est l'Allemagne moi je partage
ce qu'a dit Joachim better niche
l'Allemagne est aujourd'hui de pays le
plus bouleversé moi je dirais presque le
plus traumatisé par notamment la guerre
en nucléaire en Ukraine et le covid
pourquoi parce que les Allemands depuis
la guerre donc depuis 70 ans c'est avait
réussi à se refond une identité
allemande positive qui était fondée 1
sur la vertu du commerce pacificateur et
enrichisseur 2 sur le pacifisme allemand
3 sur les vertus de l'austérité voire de
la rigueur économique or depuis le covid
et la guerre en Ukraine tout ça c'est
effondré le commerce n'est pas un
élément de prospérité mais c'est un
élément de dépendance et de risque
maximum pour économiser la guerre le
pacifisme c'est catastrophique au moment
où il faut réarmer et l'austérité même
des Allemands ne la respectent plus
puisqu'ils sont ils ont eux-mêmes passer
au-delà des règles du pack de stabilité
et sans dette alors une dépense pas sans
compter comme des Français mais ils sont
d'aide et donc pour l'Allemagne je crois
que c'est un vrai traumatisme et
effectivement il faut être patient moi
je ne partage pas du tout l'irritation
des Français sur les animaux il faut
leur laisser le temps et il faut les
accompagner dans la reconstruction d'une
identité allemande positive donc oui
l'économie peut être un moteur à
condition de ne pas de ne pas en vouloir
à l'Allemagne de de maintenir d'essayer
de maintenir quelque chose avec la Chine
parce que elle est extrêmement
dépendante
à l'image la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale vient d'arriver
à la Sorbonne évidemment du Panthéon à
la Sorbonne c'était c'était tout près et
j'imagine que maintenant l'ensemble des
officiels vont attendre ou attendre les
deux les deux dirigeants Nicole ni les
auto je vous en prie juste un point donc
moi je crois aussi que là où on peut
rebondir c'est justement sur les
questions de sécurité de défense on a un
continent européen qui est traumatisé
par cette guerre en Ukraine dans
certains pays ont très peur des pays de
l'Est à Pologne etc l'Allemagne a décidé
d'investir 100 milliards d'euros pour sa
défense qui est quand même le doux plus
du double du budget français de la
Défense je trouve important que les deux
pays essaie de bâtir ensemble quelque
chose qui ressemblait à un livre blanc
européen sur l'avenir de la sécurité de
ouvrant ce chapitre de la défense qui
semble absolument bloquer à ce jour
Richard Werlé on découvre en fait une
forme d'axe Berlin Varsovie si on si on
prend pas la question nucléaire si on la
met de côté versovie va avoir une armée
comparable à celle de de la France
est-ce que il y a pas une recomposition
complète autour de l'OTAN avec la guerre
en Ukraine qui fait que l'idée d'une
défense commune européenne est au point
mort voire même à la poubelle oui
d'abord il y a en matière de défense et
Nicole connaissait sujet par coeur il y
a une différence fondamentale c'est que
en France il y a une méfiance vis-à-vis
des États-Unis j'ai bien j'ai dit bien
méfiance ça veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas
d'alliance mais il y a une méfiance
alors que fondamentalement en Allemagne
il y a une confiance les allemands
estiment que la garantie suprême de la
sécurité européenne ça reste les
États-Unis c'est quand même pas rien
fondamentale quand c'est aussi éloigné
la deuxième chose c'est que vous parlez
de la Pologne bien sûr que la Pologne
mais pour une raison simple la Pologne
elle est sur le disons les choses comme
elles sont elle est au contact de de
cette menace sécuritaire pour l'Europe
que constitue aujourd'hui la Russie donc
il va falloir que la Pologne elle occupe
d'abord elle prenne sa place et on voit
bien qu'il y a beaucoup de tension
autour de la place futur de la Pologne à
la fois en matière de dépenses en
matière politique maintenant est-ce que
les Allemands pour l'instant les
Allemands sont sur une ligne on dirait
on dirait ils essayent oui mais ils
essayent quand même de garder
l'équilibre en même temps il ne livre
pas ses chars à l'Ukraine on voit bien
qu'ils sont eux-mêmes embêtés par
rapport à cette arrivée je dirais
massive dans le débat sécuritaire de la
Pologne et des voisins de l'Est c'est
pas simple pour eux non plus parce que
plus l'est de l'Europe sera puissant et
je dirais investi militairement par les
États-Unis plus le risque que
l'Allemagne soit un peu non pas ignoré
mais de côté sera là l'Allemagne elle
est le bastion de la présence américaine
en Europe et c'est un rôle qu'elle ne
veut pas perdre donc c'est pas simple
son avis sur la question de la défense
en Europe défense européenne possible
au contraire c'est le temps aujourd'hui
l'horizon indépassable de cette défense
pour les 27
ou bien je dirais les militaires
allemands le premier réflexe en cas de
défense c'est le temps j'ai pas le même
réflexes à Paris à Paris j'ai je dirais
une méfiance pas seulement vis-à-vis des
États-Unis mais aussi vis-à-vis de
l'OTAN or il faut développer ensemble
sur le fond ce que Nicolas appelle avec
raison un véritable livre blanc
franco-allemand sur la défense discutant
le fond des questions ça veut dire que
l'OTAN reste le noyau dur de la défense
de notre territoire européen et que
l'Europe doivent aller au-delà
développer une certaine autonomie en
matière défense à nous il y avait cette
idée joakimlich d'un avion
franco-allemand qui a qui a mis du temps
on ne sait même pas s'il verra le jour
ça veut dire quoi concrètement des
matériels communs des opérations
communes
il faut non seulement du matériel commun
échanger du matériel entre Français et
Allemand ce qui existe
développé surtout une réflexion une
conception un réflexe commun en matière
défense là il y a le problème de fond
jusqu'au jour aujourd'hui pour le
militaire allemand sa première réflexion
en matière défense c'est l'OTAN pour le
français non le français dans sa
majorité pense d'abord à la France à la
défense de la France et ensuite ils
regardent tout ce qui est autant avec
une certaine méfiance je simplifie
Joachim n'aurait critiqué l'OTAN comme
l'a fait le président français en
parlant d'un auteur en état de mort
cérébral c'est une envie d'agable c'est
à côté Berlin
pour un Allemand un tel réflexe n'existe
pas or il faut venir au-delà et trouver
même avec nous amis américains une
nouvelle entente dans ce sens que les
Américains
non seulement nous demandent de dépenser
plus pour la défense de prendre un rôle
plus autonome mais que les Américains
l'acceptent également
et dans ce sens ma conviction et nous
avons besoin d'un nouveau pacte
transatlantique à la France à
l'Allemagne le lancer alors la question
est de savoir si Joachim biterly chez
majoritaire en Allemagne quand il dit ça
Joseph deck il parle d'autonomie il est
important ce mot on a l'impression que
l'autonomie stratégique c'est plutôt ce
que veut la France et une forme de
souveraineté stratégique c'est plutôt ce
que veut l'Allemagne mais pas
d'autonomie elle veut rester avec le
temps quel est l'état du débat au sein
de l'Allemagne au niveau de l'opinion
oui je pense en Allemagne en a décidé
qu'on peut bien vivre avec le terme de
souveraineté européenne d'ailleurs dans
le traité de coalition de cette
coalition de la chaude on parle de
souveraineté européenne ola shoot
l'utilise souvent dans ses discours
comme un objectif y compris sur les
questions de défense
souvent la déclinaison c'est plutôt
économique technologique etc mais il
parle aussi du fait que la l'Europe doit
renforcer ses capacités de défense et
qu'il faut renforcer ce qu'on appelle un
pilier européen au sein de l'OTAN
d'accord ce nouveau pacte parce que
Joakim Peter dise va assez loin il
existe dans le débat public allemand ou
pas nouveau pacte au sein de l'OTAN
je pensais à un débat qu'on est en train
d'avoir c'est exactement cette idée
qu'est-ce que l'Europe peut plus
rapporter aux États-Unis après le mot
nouveau pack comme ça en tant que
concept je l'ai pas entendu mais je
pense ce qui est un peu fondamental et
ce qui compte ce qui nous fait
comprendre aussi un peu la position
allemande et ses crispations qu'on a en
ce moment sur sur la défense c'est que
qu'on voit avec cette guerre en Ukraine
on va vraiment comment les États-Unis
sont fondamentales dans tout ça sans les
armes américains ça sera impossible
je vais réussir
mais le problème d'un couple c'est quand
vous avez un troisième conjoint et dans
ce cas de figure il y en a un troisième
conjoint qui s'arrêter les États-Unis et
là encore appelons l'histoire à la
rescousse en 1963 les États-Unis Kennedy
ont deux problèmes il y a le Vietnam en
Asie d'une part il y a eu la crise des
missiles à Cuba et donc ils ne sont
finalement les Américains sont
mentalement prêts à laisser de Gaulle et
Adenauer discuter
monter formuler un projet aujourd'hui
est très différent aujourd'hui certes
les Américains ont pour principal
priorité stratégique la Chine mais ils
sont arrimés en Europe par la guerre en
Ukraine et donc le tandem le moteur
franco-allemand il aura quand même
besoin d'un peu de carburant américain
pour fonctionner les bases militaires en
Europe et notamment en Pologne ou dans
les pays balles qui ont très très peur
de cette guerre en Ukraine si près si
près d'eux c'est l'OTAN c'est rien
d'autre l'école oui moi je crois qu'on
bâtir de défense et de sécurité il faut
distinguer l'urgence et l'ambition si on
regarde l'urgence la guerre en Ukraine
c'est évident qu'aujourd'hui il y a pas
d'alternative à l'OTAN et les Français
et les Allemands Macron est chaudes sont
d'accord là-dessus et d'ailleurs je
trouve un peu absurde que les Français
en tout cas c'était plus la presse que
le gouvernement et reproché à
l'Allemagne d'acheter des F35 américain
plutôt que des avions le canon pourquoi
parce que les Allemands sont couverts
par leur dissuasion nucléaire élargie
des États-Unis sur l'Europe et que pour
mettre en œuvre cette dissuasion si
jamais c'était nécessaire il faut mettre
des missiles airsol américain nucléaires
sur des avions de l'OTAN et ça c'est pas
possible sur les rafales
françaises nucléaires américains sur un
Rafale français de même qu'on peut pas
mettre un missile français sur un avion
américain donc en fait c'était
impossible de faire autrement d'acheter
des F-35 absolument obligé si on est
sérieux sur la dissuasion nucléaire
alors pourquoi les Français se sont
parce que en même temps c'est une
histoire industrielle qui a énormément
de c'est un avion qui a énormément de de
difficultés à se mettre en homme
maintenant je crois qu'on a on a réglé
l'affaire mais voilà de même le système
antimicile de patriote les Allemands ont
acheté américain et Israéliens parce que
c'est pareil on aurait pas pu aider nous
les Français
quelque chose mais en même temps je
considère normal que l'OTAN est une
défense antimicile avec du matériel
américain
il y a une inquiétude sur le fait que
les décisions peuvent peut-être sans
vouloir hypothéquer l'ambition or je
crois que moi l'Allemagne a toujours
cette ambition d'avoir une autonomie
européenne en matière stratégique mais
il faut faire attention que les
décisions d'aujourd'hui n'empêche pas
cette autonomie plus tard et ça je crois
que c'est un des points que chose c'est
Macron aujourd'hui à la Sorbonne vont
peut-être parce que moi je crois
contrairement à peu vous avez dit un
moment vous avez posé la question si la
défense était européenne était dans la
poubelle pas du tout encore une fois
elle n'est pas aujourd'hui une solution
d'urgence on va pas défendre
éventuellement la Pologne ou je ne sais
quelle est ta balle par la défense
européenne mais personne ne sait qu'elle
sera l'avenir de la politique américaine
dans deux ans il y a des élections si un
train prévient au pouvoir même
aujourd'hui avec une majorité
républicaine à la Chambre des
représentants aux États-Unis il est pas
évidente et repérer les républicains
continuent à vous pensez que et donc
y compris en Allemagne les dirigeants
américains l'ont en tête que si jamais
il y avait une urgence en par exemple
sur Taïwan ou si jamais les républicains
bloquaient le vote et bien il faudra
bien que les européens prennent un peu
le relais donc je crois que la défense
européenne elle est pour un horizon
stratégique différent de celui qui est
aujourd'hui l'urgence c'est-à-dire
contenait contenir la menace russe en
Ukraine alors que vous le voyez sur ces
images en direct sur LCP le grand
amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne et est
quasiment plein Gérald Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur Michaela wiggle
votre concert journaliste allemand de
Frankfurter alguemindsayung évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup de journalistes mais
aussi d'élus de députés Bruno Le Maire
pour ne pas le citer à l'image le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
qui il faut le rappeler est complètement
bilingue en allemand et qui connaît très
bien voilà la relation franco-allemande
et son et son homologue à Bercy son
homologue des finances on va on va
rejoindre cette Marco pommier pour un
dernier une dernière prise de
température Marco les chefs d'État et le
chancelier le chef d'État les chancelier
devrait ne devrait plus tarder
maintenant
oui exactement Myriam pour l'instant
nous attendons le président de la
République qui devrait arriver d'ici
quelques minutes il accueillera ensuite
Olaf scholls le chancelier allemand en
tout cas tout est prêt la garde
républicaine est prête ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que dans le quartier il
y a un gros dispositif de sécurité mais
il y a quand même quelque chose qui
peuvent assister à tout à tout cet
événement ce sont les Parisiens qui
habitent aux alentours de la Sorbonne
j'envoie quelques-uns à travers leurs
fenêtres ou leurs balcon qui regarde ce
dispositif de sécurité important et qui
sont aux premières loges pour assister à
cette cérémonie officielle en tout cas à
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron qui va se
faire maintenant d'ici quelques minutes
Richard verre je voudrais qu'on dise un
mot sur le lieu qui évidemment n'a pas
été choisi au hasard par l'Élysée la
Sorbonne on pense à au premier
quinquennat le début du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron 2017 et ce grand
discours qui a fait date on peut le dire
sur l'Europe oui et puis c'est d'abord
pour Macron une question de symbole je
dirais de sa propre présidence puisque
comme vous le dites il avait posé son
discours fondateur sur l'Europe à la
Sorbonne et donc là c'est une
continuation il y a aussi la volonté de
placer la relation franco-allemande sous
le symbole du savoir je crois que c'est
important et on le savoir ça veut dire
le temps long ça veut dire qu'on n'est
pas dans l'urgence justement et la
Sorbonne s'il y a un lieu qui symbolise
je dirais le temps long c'est la
Sorbonne ça je crois qu'il faut l'avoir
en tête et c'est aussi la question de la
culture et la question de la langue
parce que en soubassement de tout ça on
en a pas parlé mais peut-on c'est une
question ouverte peut-on avoir une
relation durable et une relation tout à
fait en symbiose si les pratiques
culturelles la pratique de la langue la
connaissance commune s'éloigne et moi
j'entends souvent mes interlocuteurs
souvent mes interlocuteurs Allemands le
disent
mutuelle qui s'est quand même beaucoup
pas cru ces deux dernières décennies et
bizarrement sa préoccupe plus les
Allemands que les Français les Français
j'en entends jamais parler je dois mes
interlocuteurs français ne trouvent
jamais que c'est un problème peut-être
parce qu'il y a une tendance assez
française à penser que après tout on n'a
pas besoin de ça les Allemands sont plus
inquiets de voir qu'il y a ce fossé
culturel mais là Joseph est un très bon
documentaire qui a été diffusé sur Arte
un couple en thérapie d'Olivier toser
récemment qui montre cette brigade
franco-allemande qui certes n'est pas
extrêmement puissante mais elle existe
et sur le terrain personne ne se parle
ni en allemand ni en français les deux
armées se parlent qu'en anglais c'est un
problème quand même
oui et non le traité de 63 le traité
qu'on est en train de célébrer
aujourd'hui en fait il a cette dimension
politique mais il a l'autre dimension
c'est de rapprocher les sociétés et
rapprocher des sociétés en l'enseignant
la langue de l'autre dans les écoles en
avoir en ayant ses échanges entre
étudiants et jeunes et je pense c'est
vrai que après 63 il y a vraiment
plusieurs générations où il y avait
énormément d'ambition de vouloir créer
des sociétés ensemble de les rapprocher
et je pense avec la globalisation
l'Europe qui est devenue plus grande ça
s'est perdu un peu après est-ce que
c'est grave qu'on parle en anglais ou en
allemand ou en français ensemble oui
bien sûr on perd quelque chose si on
parle dans une troisième langue de de
pouvoir échanger sur ses propres
cultures mais à priori je trouve c'est
quand même pas mal ce qui on se parle en
anglais et
c'est déjà pas ça et ça c'est bien et
surtout parce que le couple
franco-allemand il reste fondamental
pour mais après c'est vrai aussi que le
couple francoïma est pas aussi important
comme il a été il y a 30 ans parce que
l'Europe est devenu plus grand et c'est
très bien que maintenant l'Europe doit
se construire à plusieurs avec ce couple
français normalement mais qui doit
intégrer d'autres alors et ça c'est
clair on va le faire en anglais d'accord
avec ça est-ce qu'au fond c'est pas si
grave si la dimension linguistique voire
culturelle n'est pas à son apogée
aujourd'hui ou au contraire c'est une
priorité
je le regrette pour le dire franchement
elle m'a à mon époque on a négocié dans
les deux langues jusqu'au bout j'ai
encore appris à Bruxelles de négocier
dans les trois langues français allemand
anglais c'est regrettable mais c'est une
réalité mais déjà vu elle est à
entièrement raison pour moi le problème
de fond pour moi entre Français et
Allemand et devenu beaucoup plus ce
qu'il appelle l'ignorance mutuelle ce
que j'appelle la méconnaissance du
voisin où l'illusion du voisin c'est à
dire on se connaît pas assez on connaît
pas assez les systèmes de l'autre et je
pense le geste qu'on a vu ensemble de
deux présidentes Parlement pour moi il
significatif peut-être pour un nouveau
une nouvelle impulsion c'est l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande qui peut
avec les compétences entièrement
différentes des deux parlements avec des
conceptions différentes des partis
politiques qui sont beaucoup plus loin
l'un de l'autre et qui peuvent
développer ce que j'appelle une nouvelle
impulsion une nouvelle légitimité
franco-allemande
et on peut en parler puisque tout ça se
passe à la Sorbonne qui symbolisait la
relation entre la France et l'Allemagne
c'est Daniel Cohn-Bendit 1968 tout ça se
passe à la Sorbonne le Quartier Latin
est en révolution c'est quand même un
franco-allemand qui symbolise cette
révolte étudiante je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs il était au premier rang en
2017 parce que j'ai assisté à l'époque à
ce discours on verra évidemment s'il est
là et on essaiera de lui dans notre
premier coup c'était important le fait
que ce soit d'une personnalité et
d'ailleurs les gaullistes quand ils ont
expulsé comme Bendit l'ont expulsé comme
allemand donc c'était intéressant alors
je crois faut savoir et on me dit que
joachimiterly ce n'est pas du tout
d'accord sur l'exemple de Dani
Cohn-Bendit comme le résultat parfait de
la symbiose je vous écoute
enfin débat j'avoue je suis à 68 ans
également mais j'ai fait ma révolution
dans l'autre sens
et j'ai jamais compris la Symbolique que
les médias ont attribué à dernier combat
dead moi je le respecte comme un
personnage France allemand et qui vit en
France surtout et mais c'est tout mais
je cherche désespérément pourquoi il a
ce symbolisme porté surtout par les
côtés français parce que il était ce que
j'appelle à l'époque au premier rang des
manifestations à Paris
sans doute les Français ont le souci de
l'Incarnation ça c'est très français
Nicole niesauto est-ce que on peut
s'attendre à des nouveaux comment dire
coopération culturelle on parlait du
Parlement vous pensez vraiment que c'est
le bon endroit pour pour avancer on a
deux parlements extrêmement différents
alors il y a une nouvelle donne à
l'Assemblée nationale qui fait que on
est davantage obligé au compromis c'est
déjà c'est évidemment l'histoire même du
Bundes stack ça peut être le lieu de
l'avancée du moteur franco-allemand ça
doit être le lieu ça doit être un des
lieux de de l'avancée parce que non
seulement entre ces deux parlements mais
je crois qu'il serait très important
aussi que les députés allemands et
français au Parlement européen c'est à
dire des délégations françaises et
allemandes est également une relation
privilégiée
de façon à coopérer aussi au sein du
Parlement européen ce qui est pas
toujours évident même si au les rôles
les décisions qui sont prises au niveau
des parlements où tout se joue dans les
Conseils européens entre chef d'État ou
en bilatéral un pouvoir extraordinaire
en particulier en matière budgétaire le
Parlement et le dernier mot sur le bien
sûr dans chaque pays mais entre les deux
parlements européens entre les deux
parlements nationaux bundestaguet et
Assemblée nationale des décisions
peuvent être prises qui engagent les
deux pays non ils peuvent décider de
ratifier en même temps enfin avec les
mêmes les mêmes arguments tel ou tel
traité en particulier un traité par
exemple d'élargissement de l'Union
européenne il doit être ratifié par les
parlements on peut tout à fait imaginer
que les deux parlements décident de leur
ratifier de même jour avec des
représentants communs mais il faut que
ce soit des accords européens qui soient
soumis à légitimité
démocratique mais moi je crois
qu'effectivement il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire en matière culturelle il
y a beaucoup de choses à encore à
espérer sur le développement de la
langue allemande dans les écoles moi je
crois que ça revient on a eu quelque
chose on a eu un 50 abandon de
l'allemand au profit du chinois de du
japonais et puis ensuite du chinois j'ai
l'impression mais je veux m'avancer je
n'ai pas de chiffres j'ai l'impression
quand même que ça revient comme une
langue justement une grande langue de la
culture européenne et puis il faut aussi
le dire on a quand même une même si on
est ici à LCP on a une chaîne de
télévision Arte qui fait un travail
absolument remarquable moi je trouve que
c'est tout à fait bien et on pourrait
absolument l'Office français de la
jeunesse qui a été effectivement de la
jeunesse franco-allemande qui a été créé
par le traité de déguisée devrait avoir
son budget peut-être un peu augmenté
donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
à faire sur le plan culturel mais mais
l'essentiel me semble-t-il c'est quand
même sur la la confiance politique je
crois que c'est
il faut développer une confiance
politique entre la question c'est
comment 11h10 presque 11h11 sur LCP
normalement si les chefs d'État sont à
l'heure il aurait dit prendre la parole
il devrait prendre la parole à
5 donc 11h15 pardonnez-moi dans dans 5
minutes sans doute y aura-t-il un peu de
retard mais nous sommes ensemble pour
vivre tout cela en direct la confiance
comment on l'a construit concrètement il
y a un élément qu'on a pas abordé c'est
la question de l'énergie là on a deux
choix diamétralement opposés historiques
le nucléaire français le renouvelable
après Fukushima la fin du nucléaire
allemand là encore point de crispation
difficulté est-ce qu'on peut s'entendre
sur cette question là plafonner les prix
du gaz acheter en commun de l'énergie
pour pour essayer de s'approvisionner
sans Poutine la confiance d'abord
quelques fois elle vient quand on n'a
pas d'autre choix donc finalement la
crise elle peut avoir ce mérite c'est
qu'elle force l'Allemagne et la France à
faire des choix communs parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'alternative alors c'est pas on
rêverait d'une autre confiance mutuelle
mais après tout c'est ça le résultat de
l'histoire sur le domaine énergétique il
y a quand même un énorme hiatus qu'on
essaye de camoufler les différentes
façons mais c'est le hiatus nucléaire la
réalité c'est qu'à Paris on pense que la
solution dans les 15 années à venir aux
problèmes énergétiques européens c'est
le nucléaire et que il faut
véritablement que le nucléaire soit au
centre du jeu du côté de l'Allemagne
j'ai tourné sur ces mêmes plateaux que
un certain nombre de vos interlocuteurs
offre de records comme on dit côté
français poussaient les Allemands bien
sûr revenir au nucléaire c'est une
option pour les Français les Français se
demandent pourquoi un certain nombre
pardon de l'interlocuteurs français
notamment ceux qui travaillent sur
l'énergie se demandent pourquoi les
Allemands ne font pas ce choix à leurs
yeux réalistes de revenir au nucléaire
dans une période comme celle-ci sauf que
joachimiteriche l'a très bien dit il y
en Allemagne une coalition il y a aussi
des questions d'opinion et que le
nucléaire si j'ai bien compris la page
est définitivement tournée en Allemagne
ça entre les deux pays c'est compliqué
parce que tout le modèle énergétique
français tourne autour du nucléaire et
vous avez vu le plan d'investissement
important qui Emmanuel Macron à consenti
sur le nucléaire les futurs réacteurs
les mini-réacteurs les mini centrales
etc là je pense que cette abcès
énergétique pour l'instant il n'est pas
encore soigné et il est loin d'être
cicatrisé entre les deux pays alors que
vous le voyez ça y est les deux
présidentes descendent les marches du de
l'entrée de la Sorbonne les voitures
officielles ne devraient plus tarder
voilà vous le voyez en direct
les premiers motards est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir tout de suite voir les
différents cortèges
on va suivre ça en direct est-ce que
Marco pommier m'entend s'il le souhaite
il peut commenter en direct ce qu'il
voit autour de lui voilà
les voitures officielles le président
le président de la République va sortir
de sa voiture il va être accueilli
pariel
basse la présidente du guten Instagram
voilà Emmanuel Macron qui est en train
de sortir de sa voiture il va donc se
diriger vers la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et vers barbelbass
présidente du bundenstag allemand vous
le voyez sur ces images
voilà un poignet de main chaleureuse
du président français
qui s'entretient donc avec Barbe basse
la présidente
Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a lieu important et lieu connu
pour le président de la République qui
revient dans le grand amphithéâtre de la
Sorbonne par les Europe mais cette
fois-ci aux côtés de son homologue
allemand le chancelier Olaf scholls les
deux hommes étaient à l'Élysée ensemble
ils vont se retrouver à la tribune de ce
grand amphithéâtre
accueilli par le responsable de
l'Université de la Sorbonne le président
français
[Musique]
la première fois président
qui explique au président français
s'être recueilli avec son homologue
allemand de
sur la tombe de Simone Veil
au Panthéon
de fille et que en fait elle aurait été
très heureuse de m'avoir toutes les deux
présidents
Richard Berling oui je suis quand même
assez surpris d'une chose pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron et ola Scholt ne sont
pas arrivés ensemble à la seconde donc
je me demande la raison parce que la
symbolique là on l'a vu les deux
présidentes des assemblées sont arrivés
ensemble elles étaient ensemble au
Panthéon là il y a une petite différence
de ton exécutif le voilà qui arrive
c'est une question de seconde on va sans
doute avoir la réponse
à cette arrivée différée de la folz
voilà donc le drapeau allemand sur la
voiture officielle Marco pommier c'est à
vous
oui
qui va également sortir de son véhicule
accueilli par le Président de la
République mais également par le
président des universités
d'Île-de-France vous le voyez sur ces
images accolade entre les deux hommes
les sourires sont au rendez-vous voilà
scholls maintenant et Emmanuel Macron
qui vont rentrer voilà qui qui salue les
journalistes pour la séance photo et qui
rentre maintenant à l'intérieur de la
Sorbonne ils vont se diriger dans le
grand amphithéâtre pour cette séquence
allocution prévue qui devait être prévu
aux alentours de 11h15 et un petit peu
de retard mais voilà ça y est les deux
hommes sont en train de rentrer à
l'intérieur de l'université
et on le voit les poignées de mains sont
chaleureuses les sourires au rendez-vous
et me dit-on pas de mauvaise manière
côté allemand c'est le protocole que le
président soit avant pour accueillir son
homologue
voilà de femmes de hommes l'image est
forte le Parlement côté allemand côté
français représenté par deux présidents
pour le commentaire un jour peut-être
en tout cas l'Allemagne a déjà connu une
chancelière
et quelle chancelière avec une stabilité
voilà la Garde Républicaine le drapeau
européen le drapeau français le drapeau
allemand et ses grands amphithéâtre
rempli à la fois d'élus d'officiel du
gouvernement et puis d'étudiants
également venus écouter ces deux
discours deux discours qui devraient
beaucoup moins loin Richard Berli que le
grand discours de la Sorbonne qui avait
duré plus d'une heure on nous annonce
deux discours de 15 minutes et puis
peut-être quelques annonces on verra sur
quel sujet sans doute des éléments
concernant la politique commerciale en
tous les cas dans le Journal du Dimanche
cette tribune commune
tentait à montrer que la volonté
d'avancer le mot de pacte de nouveaux
pacte a été prononcé alors que vous
voyez à l'image Valérie rabot député
Elvis présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale salué Bruno Le Maire peut-être
si vous deviez nous dire voilà les
meilleurs discours qu'est-ce que vous
attendez vous personnellement de ce
moment là nikoniizotto
moi j'attends deux choses d'une part une
réflexion sur le franco-allemand
l'Europe qui soit ancré dans la réalité
du monde que l'on vit non pas un
discours sur l'Europe en général mais
l'Europe dans ce chaos de la
mondialisation je voudrais que les deux
chefs d'État tentent d'expliquer les
crises que nous vivons et des crises du
franco-allemand par rapport à
l'évolution de la situation
internationale parce que très souvent on
a l'impression qu'on fait du
franco-allemand qu'on fait de l'Europe
comme si on était des bulles perdus dans
une stratosphère et que les contraintes
extérieures n'existaient pas ça c'est le
premier point d'expliquer aux gens à
quel point la situation est difficile et
peut-être grave deuxièmement ce que
j'attends évidemment c'est un comment
dit-on une feuille de route pour
l'avenir on a des crises on a des
divergences on a un vrai problème
aujourd'hui avec les Américains sur le
retour du protectionnisme commercial
américain moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
une feuille de route c'est à dire voilà
des propositions franco-allemandes pour
créer une proposition européenne et
discutée avec les Américains je crois
que ce que ce qu'il faudrait c'est que
le ces deux chefs d'État montrent
quelle est la valeur du couple
franco-allemand non pas en tant que tel
mais pour entrer une position commune
des Européens et ça c'est sur la guerre
en Ukraine je crois que c'est très
important
moi je ne supporte pas avec
pardonnez-moi l'idée que les Polonais se
permettent d'insulter ou de disputer des
Allemands parce qu'ils ne vendent pas de
leur char léopard il faut quand même
réfléchir un peu
sûr évidemment le commerce et donc sur
la défense sur le commerce et puis sur
l'énergie oui la question de la des
chars des livraisons d'armes alors que
vous le voyez ça y est
le président français le chancelier
allemand
ovationné
par cette grande salle de
Richelieu l'amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne
tout sourire et de présidente sont
également sur les Strad
c'était évidemment la guerre en Ukraine
qui est dans toutes les têtes
aujourd'hui aussi avec beaucoup de
critiques qui montent notamment à l'est
sur un soutien trop timoré trop prudent
et une indulgence peut-être un peu trop
grande vis-à-vis de Vladimir Poutine au
procès qui est fait aussi bien la France
mais aussi à l'Allemagne oui ce qu'on
attend de ce discours de ces deux
discours c'est à la fois quand même en
tout cas pour moi une expression de
sentiments mutuelle il faut que le cœur
parle et il faut qu'il y ait des
certitudes donc des points d'ancrage
donc on va voir si les deux chefs de
l'exécutif sont à même de les formuler
qui inaugure cette série de quatre
discours la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale à la tribune de ce grand
amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne on va
l'écouter en direct sur LTB
monsieur le Président de la République
Monsieur le Chancelier
madame la Présidente du bundeslag
monsieur le Président du bundeslat
monsieur le vice-président du Sénat
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les députés des
deux rives du Rhin chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs
il me revient l'honneur d'ouvrir cette
journée franco-allemande
durant laquelle nous commémorons
ensemble le 60e anniversaire du traité
de l'Élysée du 22 janvier 1963
et ce n'est pas un hasard si je prends
la parole ici à la Sorbonne là où tout a
commencé
car il y a 7 siècles de cela dans
l'enceinte et studiantine créée par
Robert de Sorbonne on trouvait une
nation française et une nation allemande
étroitement liés dans déjà dans le
travail
l'étude et la recherche
à l'époque en effet à la Sorbonne ce
terme de nation recouvrait tous les
étudiants natifs d'une même partie du
monde
en cette université vouée à la
découverte des humanités classiques la
nation française englobelle les élèves
originaires des pays latins la France
l'Espagne le Portugal les États italiens
et la nation allemande tous ces jeunes
de leur reprennent et nordique vos
prédécesseurs chers européens
venus si nombreux à Paris qu'il fallut
bientôt distinguer
nation de la haute Allemagne et nations
de Bass Allemagne
ainsi les nations sens de la Sorbonne
n'étaient-elles pas des groupes hostiles
et chauvins
simplement des collectivités humaines
chacune avait sa langue sa culture ses
us et coutures auquel il n'était pas
question de renoncer
mais chacune voulait aussi connaître les
coutumes cultures et langues des autres
nations
pour bâtir quelque chose de plus grand
avec elle
et en 7 siècles malgré les guerres et
les drames malgré le sang versé sur tous
les champs de bataille du monde les
esprits éclairés n'ont rien voulu
d'autres que d'étendre au continent le
miracle de la Sorbonne pour que les
nations deviennent des familles au sein
d'un vaste ensemble européen
c'est ainsi que l'histoire de France
l'histoire d'Allemagne n'ont en fait
cessé de se mêler de se mélanger pour
former une seule et même histoire
franco-allemande dont toutes et tous ici
sommes en définitive les héritiers
ce n'est pas un voeu pieux c'est une
réalité qui est facile de constater
l'un des plus charmants monument de
l'agglomération berlinoise porte un nom
français sans souci vous Frédéric II
recevait Voltaire et le plus célèbre des
Monuments français porte un nom allemand
Eiffel région rénale dont était issues
la famille de gustaveys Eiffel né Bonnie
Housen
le Rhin on le voit n'est pas un fossé
entre nos deux peuples et Gaël avait
ainsi raison de dire qu'un fleuve n'est
pas ce qui sépare mais ce qui rassemble
et toute notre art politique consiste
sans doute à bâtir des ponts
après égal c'est Hugo qui écrivait dès
1842 il faut pour que l'univers soit en
équilibre qu'il y en Europe comme la
double clé de voût du continent deux
grands États du rap tous deux fécondés
et étroitement unis par ce fleuve
régénérateur
le grand écrivain venait de voyager à
travers la vallée du Rhin il en tirait
un splendide récit conclu ainsi la
France et l'Allemagne sont
essentiellement l'Europe
combien de huguenos Français ont franchi
le rein pour trouver asile en terre
allemande et y faire souche
combien de citoyens allemands plus tard
fuyant le nazisme on recherchait en
France un havre de liberté
j'en parle en connaissance de cause moi
petite fille d'une citoyenne de Munich
réfugiée en Lorraine
et si j'évoque ici le souvenir de Rosa
ma grand-mère né allemande
épouse d'un réfugié polonais tous deux
naturalisé français c'est pour vous dire
simplement
serait fière et émue de nous voir
aujourd'hui
tenant cette promesse devenue réalité
tangible
cela grâce à l'esprit de responsabilité
qui a su prévaloir des deux côtés du
Rhin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis sûre qu'elle vous a entendu
le mois dernier à l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai fait à poser une plaque en
l'honneur d'un grand orateur
parlementaire d'autrefois Aristide
Briand il fut député ministre chef du
gouvernement pendant la bataille de
Verdun
la paix revenue et Farid par les
massacres et les destructions d'une
guerre mondiale il levra de toutes ses
forces pour la paix le rapprochement
franco-allemand et les États-Unis
d'Europe en 1926 il reçut le prix Nobel
de la Paix conjointement avec son
homologue allemand stress the man et
quand dans l'hémicycle du Palais Bourbon
les députés français lui demandèrent de
rendre compte de ces échanges avec le
gouvernement de la République de Weimar
voilà la réponse qu'il lance ça et que
je vous invite à méditer
nous avons parlé l'Européen c'est une
langue nouvelle qu'il faudra bien que
l'on apprenne
la grande crise de 1929 la montée des
nations des nationalistes ont empêché
cette vision de se réaliser tout de
suite
mais une deuxième guerre mondiale plus
tard nous savons nous démocrates nous
humanistes des deux rives du Rhin que
c'est Aristide Briand qui avait raison
c'est pourquoi il y a 60 ans le 22
janvier 1963 le général de Gaulle et le
chancelier à donauer signait cette
extraordinaire traité de l'Elysée qui
redonnait des bases solides concrètes et
rénovées à l'amitié franco-allemande les
nations au sens de la Sorbonne
l'emportait sur le nationalisme
l'ouverture sur la fermeture les gens
fructueux sur le repli frileux
et c'est ainsi que nous avons connu fait
unique dans l'histoire si décennies de
Concorde et de paix
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui je veux le dire avec force
l'amitié franco-allemand est un bien
précieux
partout nous entendons les codes et
vieux discours populistes et xénophobes
qui ont fait tant de mal et sur notre
flanc oriental nous avons vu ressurgir
leur conséquences fatales la guerre
notre responsabilité et Dénoyer ses
spectres ses forces de destruction et de
désolation que nous récusons ensemble
l'amitié franco-allemande c'est
l'antidote au poison qui part deux fois
ont failli emporté l'Europe le
nationalisme et l'expansionnisme c'est
un gage tout à la fois de démocratie et
de prospérité pour le présent bien sûr
et plus encore pour l'avenir
jeunes Allemands jeunes Français jeunes
Européens qui est ici présent c'est
votre génération qui doit s'emparer de
cet héritage et le faire fructifier
c'est votre génération qui va construire
l'avenir
et notre première investissement c'est
vous c'est la jeunesse franco-allemande
qui va transformer le monde car nous le
voyons bien les grands chantiers du
futur sont d'abord franco-allemand rien
industrialisation transition énergétique
coopération scientifique et culturelle
promotion des valeurs démocratiques
européennes
quelles sont les grands enjeux qui
constituent pour nos deux pays pour leur
jeunesse autant de formidables
opportunités de renouveau et de progrès
vous le voyez l'esprit qui anime notre
partenariat franco-allemand
[Musique]
ignore le pessimisme et la morosité
quand d'autres se réfugient dans le
protectionnisme nous disons concertation
confiance et initiative commune
60 ans après le chancelier de Noël et le
général de Gaulle monsieur le Président
de la République Monsieur le Chancelier
vous apprêtez à nouer un nouveau
partenariat franco-allemand c'est le
sens de l'histoire et nous pouvons tous
nous en réjouir
[Applaudissements]
juste avant de prendre la parole ici
devant vous j'étais au Panthéon avec mon
homologue berbel bass
symboliquement nous avons voulu rendre
hommage à Simone Veil
ancienne déportée première présidente du
Parlement européen
dans ce temple des grands hommes nous
avons salué la mémoire d'une grande dame
qui disait fort justement avec cette
lucidité qui était sa signature
politique
l'Europe c'est avant tout la fin des
conflits entre la France et l'Allemagne
c'est déjà acquis depuis maintenant un
peu plus de 20 ans mais il faut
poursuivre dans cette voie et dans une
perspective de confiance et de
construction ensemble
comme elle avait raison
le nouveau partenariat franco-allemand
va également être relancé grâce à notre
déclaration commune cher berbel
déclaration qui nommait aucun champ
d'intervention car nos assemblées se
sont jumelés elle s'engageront toujours
plus pour le progrès j'en suis sûr et le
programme aujourd'hui est
franco-allemand pour promouvoir l'amitié
entre nos deux pays et avec elle nos
valeurs démocratiques nos exigences
écologiques notre vigilance sur le droit
des femmes je sais pouvoir compter sur
toi cher berbel et je suis heureuse de
te céder la parole je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
zeden monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Chancelier
monsieur les présidents du Sénat
français du Bundes
de nos pays et dans l'histoire de
l'Europe il y a 60 ans
une amitié qui est devenue le moteur de
l'unification européenne le terme de
réconciliation n'apparaît pas dans le
traité de l'Élysée mais ce traité
représente une réconciliation sans
précédent entre deux nations et pour un
nouvel esprit de la meilleure
compréhension
18 années nous parles séparées
que l'Allemagne avait infligé à l'Europe
la Première Guerre mondiale dévastatrice
était elle aussi encore très présente
dans la mémoire collective la
réconciliation existe à la fois du
courage de l'humanité de la générosité
et dans la société civile il y a eu très
tôt des personnes qui se sont prononcées
en faveur d'un véritable processus de
réconciliation des personnalités aussi
clairvoyantes que Charles de Gaulle
on fait avancer cette entente je
m'incline avec une profonde gratitude et
un profond respect devant toutes les
personnes qui se sont engagées pour
surmonter l'hostilité et construire
l'amitié entre nos pays
[Applaudissements]
il faut briser le cercle vicieux il
fallait le briser la réconciliation
franco-allemande serait la pierre
angulaire de la construction d'une
Europe apaisée fin de citation
en tant que jeune adolescente Simone
Veil avait survécu
elle a perdu sa mère son père et son
frère dans la Shoah et pourtant elle a
trouvé la force de tendre la main aux
oiseaux toute sa vie elle s'est engagée
pour la réconciliation entre la France
et l'Allemagne chez Madame présidente
merci de m'avoir invité à me recueillir
avec vous sur la tombe de Simone Veil au
Panthéon
rendre hommage à cette femme
exceptionnelle a profondément ému
modèle un grand exemple en tant que
réconciliatrice convaincu européenne
visionnaire et fervente militante des
droits de la femme certains
[Applaudissements]
si l'idée européenne pouvait encore être
comprise comme idée de paix au Projet de
paix la paix semblait aller de soi
surtout pour la jeune régénération mais
la guerre d'agression menée par la
Russie contre l'Ukraine précédé en 2014
par l'annexion illégale de la Crimée
nous montre nous
l'avertissement de Jean-Claude Juncker
est douloureusement actuel ceux qui
doutent de l'Europe ceux qui désespèrent
de l'Europe et bien il devrait visiter
les cimetières militaires
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour en Europe dans une guerre
criminelle
l'Europe se tient fermement et
indéfectiblement aux côtés de l'Ukraine
nous soutenons les Ukrainiennes et les
Ukrainiens dans leur lutte pour la
liberté la souveraineté l'intégrité
territoriale tout comme il est réfugiés
ukrainien
à se reconstruire et à rejoindre l'Union
européenne
dès les premiers instants de cette
guerre l'Europe a fait preuve d'une
solidarité sans faille avec l'Ukraine et
d'une grande unité face à l'agresseur
russe
est également dans notre intérêt il en
va de la sécurité de notre continent de
notre prospérité et de notre mode de vie
des valeurs qui nous unissent de la
liberté de l'État de droit et de la
démocratie
contre des attaques venant de la période
ce n'est que si l'Europe est forte de
l'intérieur que nous pourrons affirmer
nos valeurs sur le plan international
l'Europe est confrontée à des tâches
immenses les bouleversements
géopolitiques le changement climatique
l'approvisionnement énergétique
l'économie ou les mouvements migratoires
exigent de nous de nouvelles réponses
communes l'Allemagne et la France sont
plus que jamais sollicités et notre
partenariat joue un rôle clé dans la
réalisation des grandes taches de notre
époque
de notre concertation jouant un rôle
essentiel pour l'avenir de nos pays et
de l'Union européenne
nous avons des traditions et des
cultures constitutionnelles différentes
et cela se reflète également dans des
idées politiques différentes sur
certaines questions cela fait également
partie d'une amitié notre force réside
de dans la transformation de nos
différences en progrès pour l'Europe a
besoin du tendon franco-allemand et nous
parlerons ont une responsabilité tout à
fait particulière à cet égard
[Musique]
S sont sous pression et que la confiance
de nombreux citoyens dans le monde
politique s'affaiblit de manière
inquiétante la démocratie est aussi
forte que c'est par Le Mans et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il est tellement
important pour moi que nous continuerons
approfondir notre coopération
parlementaire franco-allemande je
considère qu'il est la responsabilité de
nos parlements d'approfondir leurs
échanges et d'élaborer sur cette base
des positions communes et c'est
exactement ce que nous ferons cet
après-midi lors de la séance de travail
de l'Assemblée nationale et du bundeslak
la politique étrangère parlementaire
s'est établi
grâce à de nombreux députés très engagés
à large réseau se développer entre le
Bundes stats et l'Assemblée nationale
de 2019
nos parlements ont véritablement fait
passer la coopération à un niveau
supérieur l'impulsion a d'ailleurs été
donnée par votre discours passionné de
2017 ici à la Sorbonne monsieur le
Président Macron
[Applaudissements]
rapidement répondu à votre appel pour
insuffler une nouvelle dynamique dans
nos relations et ils ont créé ce
Parlement binational c'est une première
mondiale et je tiens ici à remercier
volcan et Richard Ferrand pour leur
engagement ils ont tous les deux étaient
les moteurs de ce projet
[Applaudissements]
notre jeune assemblée parlementaire à
non seulement été capable de travailler
pendant la pandémie mais elle a
également gagné en visibilité cela
montre la force de ce partenariat
franco-allemand dans son ensemble et
cela témoigne d'une véritable confiance
mutuelle il me tient clairement à cœur
d'utiliser intensivement l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande et de la
développer et là dessus je suis
pleinement d'accord avec mon homologue
à l'occasion de cet anniversaire
nous voulons ainsi continuer à renforcer
notre coopération parlementaire
rechercher des solutions franco
allemande qui favorisent son processus
d'intégration en Europe et cet
anniversaire est une bonne occasion de
relancer le
dernier prix était décerné il y a 7 ans
déjà nous avions décidé de créer ce prix
à l'occasion du 40e anniversaire du
traité de l'Élysée et récompense des
ouvrages scientifiques qui contribuent à
une meilleure connaissance mutuelle de
nos deux pays madame et Messieurs après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale il était
clair que seul de nouvelles approche
permettrait de surmonter la haine et
l'hostilité en Europe
la réconciliation la compréhension ne
pouvait néanmoins pas rester un projet
des élites vous avez besoin d'une
participation aussi large que possible
de la population de rencontres entre
citoyennes et citoyens un réseau de plus
en plus dense de jumelage de ville à vu
le jour compte aujourd'hui plus de 2200
partenariats franco-allemand impliquant
des villes des départements des régions
des jumelages
particulièrement intense dans les
régions frontalières nous avons pu
constater lors de la pandémie à quel
point nos relations économiques
culturelles et social au quotidien sont
devenus étroites
devenues comme avant la pandémie à
savoir à chaîne perceptible nous sommes
et Messieurs après l'échec du référendum
constitutionnel de 2005 Simone Veil
avait déclaré
les gens qui sont convaincus de
l'évidence de l'Europe nous n'avons pas
réussi à leur faire comprendre le
contraire fin de citation
en Europe au cours des dernières
décennies ne va certainement pas de soi
et nous n'oublions parfois
également
pour l'amitié franco-allemande
laquelle je suis si heureuse que des
jeunes venus de France et d'Allemagne
participent à cette cérémonie merci à
tous d'être là
à buvres
c'est déjà pour vous dire ceci continuez
à vous engager pour l'amitié
franco-allemande pour la démocratie et
pour l'Europe et surtout contaminez
d'autres jeunes avec votre enthousiasme
il en va de l'avenir et la construction
de l'avenir est particulièrement entre
les mains de la jeune génération et
d'ailleurs depuis le début la jeunesse a
toujours été essentielle à notre
réconciliation 35 000 participants ce
sont réunis en 1951 lors de la rencontre
Robin de la jeunesse à la Lorelei et il
s'est principalement de jeunes allemands
et de jeunes Français en 1963 c'est
l'Office Franco-Allemand pour la
Jeunesse qui a été créée une institution
qui depuis 60 ans contribue de manière
extraordinaire à l'intérêt mutuel à la
compréhension et à notre amitié si
étroite et je voudrais profiter de pour
remercier tout particulièrement les
citoyennes les citoyens qui ont
construit cette amitié en notre pays
entre nos pays qui l'ont vécu et qui
l'ont sans cesse renouer et c'est sur
eux que nous continuons de compter tout
particulièrement
[Applaudissements]
notre amitié si particulière avec de
nouvelles idées de nouvelles impulsions
soyons ambitieux pour l'avenir de nos
pays et pour l'avenir en Europe je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
de la France et de l'Allemagne soit
éliminer
12 ans plus tard en signant le traité de
l'Élysée
plusieurs siècles d'hostilité
héréditaire entre l'Allemagne et la
France
le début d'une nouvelle ère de
coopération qui au fil des ans elle est
devenue une amitié indestructible une
affection fraternelle
aujourd'hui c'est facile à dire
il y a 60 ans lorsque fut signé le
traité de l'Elysée
moins de 20 ans c'était écoulé depuis la
fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
déclenchée par l'Allemagne et ses
terribles ravages
les blessures infligées n'étaient pas
apaisées et encore moins guéri
comment aurait-il pu d'ailleurs en être
autrement compte tenu des crimes commis
contre l'humanité c'est donc avec
d'autant plus d'émotions que nous
allemands voyons la grandeur humaine du
peuple français qui malgré tout en dépit
de tous les doutes justifiés nous
attendons la main en signe de
réconciliation
[Applaudissements]
ce geste de réconciliation historique a
marqué le début de l'unification
européenne
tout particulièrement le rôle de la
France en tant que nation indispensable
dans la construction de notre Europe
unie
indispensable la France l’était hier et
elle le reste aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
nous
sommes profondément reconnaissants qu'il
en soit ainsi président
merci de tout cas merci à vous nos
frères et soeurs français pour votre
amitié
cette amitié
elle représente beaucoup pour nous et
plus encore cette main que nous
attendons la France et les 60 années de
paix ont vécu nos deux pays depuis
engendre pour nous allemand une
responsabilité particulière
de renforcer nos points en commun et de
ne plus admettre aucune division
les responsabilités d'entretenir notre
intérêt l'un pour l'autre et
d'approfondir nos connaissances
mutuelles sur nos cultures notre
littérature
et notre art nos langues comme le font
des millions de citoyennes et citoyens
de nouvelles amicalement
et une multitude de rencontres humaines
j'avais déjà pu me rendre compte de
l'intensité de ces liens au cours de
nombreuses idées
ne le rappelle puisque son lycée
franco-allemand date de cette époque
[Applaudissements]
enfin en tant qu'ami français nous
partageons les responsabilités de mettre
notre partenariat au service d'une
Europe pacifique et unie
de ceux qui se sont tendus la main
par-dessus les tombes des deux guerres
mondiales Charles de Gaulle et
conradaware
c'est ce vécu précisément qui les
incitaient à laisser derrière eux tout
idéalisation nationaleiste
leur projet de paix initial est
aujourd'hui achevé et c'est un bonheur
pour nous tous
[Applaudissements]
pour nous qui sommes dans la paix la
liberté une guerre entre nos nations une
guerre entre les États membres de
l'Union européenne est en effet
inconcevable
nous que d'aucun craignent même que cela
ne nous fasse perdre notre motivation à
faire avancer l'Europe or ce serait
totalement faux et imprudent
devront faire face en radicalement
changé
de nos jours il ne s'agit plus d'éviter
une guerre à l'intérieur de notre union
mais de préserver et de défendre notre
ordre de paix européen et nos valeurs
contre les forces centrifuges qui
existent au sein de notre union et
surtout contre les menaces venant de
l'extérieur
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs en quoi
consiste le Projet de paix européen en
se tournant historique que nous vivons
l'amitié franco-allemande offre
également une assise solide car notre
amitié symbolise une Europe unie et un
ordre de paix fondé sur les principes de
la Charte des Nations Unies
le respect des droits fondamentaux et
des libertés de tout individu établies
par beau prédécesseurs
les députés de l'Assemblée nationale
en 1789 l'année de la République
par Jean-Jacques Rousseau philosophie
lumière et par la suite la pensée de
comte qui considérait l'État de droit
comme un rempart contre tout pouvoir
arbitraire de l'État
démocratique venant de France qui a
commencé aussi
sans raciner malheureusement par trop
timidement sur le sol allemand il y a
165 ans
et enfin l'idée c'est des sociétés
libérales et solidaires
société européenne donc
la responsabilité individuelle le
respect de chaque citoyen et de chaque
citoyen
après s'être libéré de leur dictature
les Grecs les Espagnols et les Portugais
sont procrastivement venus rejoindre
notre communauté
par les acquis de l'Europe unie pour
finir après la chute du rideau de fer
les pays d'Europe centrale et orientale
se sont à l'heure
démocratie leur soif de liberté et leur
désir de démocratie ont ravivé et
enrichi notre union
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes parvenus à repousser le
droit du plus fort par la force du droit
dans l'Union européenne et sur
l'ensemble du continent européen
la guerre d'agression russe contre le
crâne à brutalement mi faim à se établit
à l'échelle du continent
le président de Vladimir Poutine a
divisé impérialistes ils cherchent à
déplacer les frontières par la force les
Ukrainiennes et les Ukrainiens en paix
le prix terrible
pas
[Applaudissements]
aux côtés de nos voisins et partenaires
écriront les prochains chapitres de
l'histoire européenne et nous ne
laisserons pas le rapport
où la violence remplacée la politique et
où la haine et les rivalités nationales
déchiraient notre continent
on témoigne notamment nos décisions
prises ces derniers jours
on nettoie de constatation
de alukraine de véhicules blindés de
combat d'infanterie et de reconnaissance
nous continuerons de fournir l'Ukraine
aussi longtemps que nécessaire
le soutien dont elle aura besoin pour
défendre notre projet de paix européen
cette volonté commune cette
détermination constitue un pas décisif
vers une Europe souveraine
une exposait dans cette même enceinte
chéri manuel il y a plus de 5 ans je
t'en suis très reconnaissant
aujourd'hui nous nous efforçons côte à
côte de renforcer la souveraineté de
l'Europe en unissant nos fours dans les
domaines où les États-nations seules ont
perdu de leur efficacité
de faire respecter nos valeurs dans le
monde et de protéger notre démocratie
contre les forces autoritaires
mais aussi de nous affirmer dans la
course aux nouvelles technologies
l'accès aux matières premières
l'approvisionnement en énergie ou le
domaine spatial
cela ne veut pas dire justement
abandonner la souveraineté nationale ou
la remplacer mais au contraire préserver
et renforcer cette dernière dans un
monde en rapide mutation
de nouveaux centres de pouvoir se créer
des pays et des formes de gouvernement
complètement différents ces livres une
lutte de pouvoir d'influence et
d'opportunités
il se peut que nous nous trouvions face
à un changement d'époque bien plus
important encore un changement d'époque
vers un multipolaire auquel nous ne
pouvons pas répondre par en replie
nationale
un monde dans lequel nous ne
subsisterons pas comme petite Europe
frileuse en trois aux égoïsmes nationaux
et creusant des feux fossés entre l'Est
et l'Ouest le Nord et le Sud
répondait en substance à une question
qu'on lui posait concernant les
frontières de l'Europe unie au nord et à
l'ouest l'Atlantique forme une frontière
naturelle au sud c'est la Méditerranée
mais à l'Est cette frontière est ouverte
floue
d'autant plus important de dire
solidairement en tant qu'Union
européenne comme nous l'avons fait l'été
dernier oui l'Ukraine et le moloba et à
terme la Géorgie font partie de notre
famille européenne oui les six pays des
Balkans occidentaux en font également
partie depuis longtemps pour être franc
tous
dans leur place dans une Union
européenne élargie une Union européenne
a pacifier notre continent
et capable d'agir sur le plan
géopolitique
[Applaudissements]
il nous reste cependant un long chemin à
parcourir
il convient d'assurer la capacité
d'action de cette Union élargie par des
réformes institutionnelles et surtout
l'Union européenne géopolitique doit
devenir un acteur fort et crédible sur
la scène mondiale
University à l'université Charles de
Prague
centrale j'ai fait cet été quelques
propositions à ce sujet
concernant notamment la politique de
sécurité
concrètement il s'agit d'améliorer la
synergie de nos efforts en matière de
défense de resserrer la coopération de
nos industries de l'armement et
d'assurer un développement coordonné de
nos capacités européennes
c'est pourquoi il est si important que
nous développions ensemble la prochaine
génération d'avions et de Charles de
combat européens en Allemagne et en
France et en association avec nos amis
espagnols il est tout aussi important
que nous assurions la viabilité du
modèle économique et social européens et
ce sans nous laisser leurrer par ceux
qui parlent de démondialisation ou
préconise le découplage
notre prospérité laquelle repose au
contraire sur l'ouverture le commerce
libre l'innovation et la concurrence
l'oréale
en même temps nous ne continuerons pas à
ignorer le fait que par le passé nous ne
sommes parfois trop appuyés sur certains
pays fournisseurs ou acheteurs
nous choisissons de la diversification
car elle nous permettra de réduire les
dépendances
unilatéralesment en matière première et
en énergie ainsi que le renforcement de
nos relations commerciales à l'échelle
mondiale avec nos partenaires de
l'Amérique du Nord et du sud de l'un de
Pacifique et de
l'afriquements grâce auxquels nous
ferons de l'Union européenne un pôle
mondial des technologies du futur
et le premier continent du monde
climatique
[Applaudissements]
fait partie d'une Europe géopolitique
souveraine je suis heureux chère
Emmanuelle que nous partageions ces
objectifs
[Musique]
comme locomotive d'une Europe unie
qui dépasse les différences existantes
entre eux et entre les pays d'Europe
ensemble nous y parviendrons je n'en
doute pas et ce notamment grâce à ton
engagement indéfectible pour l'Europe
cher Emmanuel et à notre amitié
[Applaudissements]
doucement et de manière à peine audible
comme c'est souvent le cas
le moteur franco-allemand est une
machine de compromis une machine bien
graissée mais qui parfois peut être
bruyante et témoigne d'un travailleur dû
flatterie et de symbolique vie de sens
ce qui le fait marcher c'est notre ferme
volonté de toujours transformer les
contreses et les intérêts divergents en
une action convergente
car nous le savons
c'est lorsque nous parvenons à trouver
des compromis en dépit de nos
différentes structures éthiques et
économiques en dépit de la disparité de
nos institutions politiques et en dépit
de nos mémoires collectives de nos
traditions d'État nation et de notre Gé
tellement différente que c'est des
signes des solutions également porteuses
pour d'autres
et nous le savons cela présence à nos
côtés de l'autre l'ami le plus proche
partenaire fraternel en tant que couple
fraternel
peut permettre aussi à notre propre pays
de s'assurer un bon avenir
[Applaudissements]
d'un fond européen de relance
de même dans la situation actuelle nous
nous soutenons mutuellement imaginons de
l'électricité de l'Allemagne vers la
France et inversement du gaz de la
France vers les manières
se traduit ainsi par une solidarité
réelle concrète
entre nos gouvernements y contribue la
séance nocturnes à Bruxelles y contribue
et il nous conseille des ministres comme
aujourd'hui où il s'agit d'aboutir à des
résultats tangibles pour nos sites Yann
et nos citoyens y contribuent eux aussi
si l'on y sache bien
c'est précisément au quotidien
pour nous comme une seconde nature que
réside sont caractères vraiment
exceptionnel
son caractère unique
de notre amitié indestructible de notre
affection fraternelle pour façonner
ensemble avec nos partenaires aux
Européens le présent et l'avenir de
notre continent
[Applaudissements]
mesdames les présidentes du Bundestag et
de l'Assemblée nationale
monsieur le Président du bundeslat
monsieur le vice-président du Sénat
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
Monsieur le Recteur cher jeunes
allemands français européen Mesdames et
Messieurs chers amis
je suis très heureux
très heureux de vous retrouver pour
célébrer comme vous venez de le faire à
l'instant tout trois l'amitié
franco-allemande
entre nous
et avec vous représentante et
représentants de nos parlements nos
gouvernements nos sociétés civiles et
nos jeunesses
nos deux pays
jumeaux d'histoire et de destin
ont vécu tant d'années en miroir
dans la forge même de leur identité
ils ont alterné pendant tant de siècles
entre l'émulation la fascination la
compétition
unis sous la même couronne franque
jusqu'à ce que l'histoire ne les sépare
car il lieu 1000 ans avant les tranchées
de Verdun le traité de Verdun
rivaux ou alliés et demi jusqu'à la
déraison au cours d'époque où l'on
comptait ce temps commun au rythme des
guerres avant entre et après
si bien que parler de l'Allemagne pour
un Français
c'est toujours parler d'une part
de soi-même
pourtant il a fallu pour accepter cette
part respectif d'altérité si proche
d'identité si confondante
l'acte fondateur que nous commémorons
aujourd'hui
le 22 janvier 1963
l'Allemagne de conradenauer et la France
du général de Gaulle
accomplissait un immense geste de
courage
ce jour-là nos deux pays qui avaient été
les plus apres ennemis décidé de devenir
les plus étroits alliés
il refermait presque 100 ans de guerre
moderne et de tragédie une universelle
que nous rappelle encore aujourd'hui les
rangées de croix s'étendant un infini
dans nos cimetières militaires
ce jour-là
en scellant leur réconciliation
nos deux pays décidaient d'ouvrir toute
grande les portes d'un avenir nouveau
pour l'Allemagne pour la France pour
l'Europe et par conséquent pour le monde
selon les mots du général de Gaulle
60 ans après sa signature
le traité de l'Élysée demeure
le socle de ce lien inaltérable
exemplaire entre nos deux pays unis pour
la paix la liberté la défense de nos
valeurs démocratiques
unis dans le rêve commun de l'Europe à
la faveur de mille fibres tissées d'une
rive l'autre du Rhin à travers ses
routes millénaires
oui
nous sommes toutes et tous aujourd'hui
les enfants de ce courage
convoqués au-delà des épreuves
par une génération sur laquelle
plusieurs fois la guerre avait laissé sa
marque
qui refusait de léguer la fatalité du
combat et du chagrin à la suivante
et qui pour cela fondait son espoir sur
la jeunesse
et nous devons ainsi fondateurs de sans
cesse enseigner à la génération suivante
le chemin parcouru d'expliquer et
d'enrichir encore cette victoire de
l'amitié si parfaite aujourd'hui
que ces racines douloureuses pourraient
s'oublier
c'est pourquoi
cette amitié
se doit de ne jamais cesser
d'être ce qu'elle est
pour détourner une formule
qui
j'ai 10 était employés pour la France
seule mais que je reconvoque en ces
lieux pensant à Renan pour nous deux
cette amitié est un plébiscite de tous
les jours
le geste fait il y a 60 ans était un
geste de courage car il n'avait rien
d'évident
tout documenté dans les vies de chacun
la nécessité de ne pas faire ou de faire
le contraire
les histoires de ces générations de
fondateurs leur disaient le contraire
et ils l'ont fait
notre amitié et ce plébiscite de tous
les jours qui repose sur une volonté une
coopération une confiance qui doivent
irriguer l'ensemble de nos institutions
de nos sociétés de nos forces vives mais
jamais ce combat ne peut être ni ne sera
celui
des fatigué des habitués et de ceux qui
ne regardent que le passé jamais
c'est aussi pourquoi il y a quatre ans à
Aix-la-Chapelle nous avons signé un
nouveau traité d'amitié
actant le succès historique de notre
réconciliation permise par le traité de
l'Élysée nous avons décidé
d'approfondir notre intégration et nos
convergences dans tous les domaines
au service de l'Union européenne de la
paix de notre transition
environnementale et numérique pour les
jeunesses de nos deux pays pour nos
concitoyens qui vivent et travaillent de
part et d'autre de nos frontières
et avec vous Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires grâce à l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande institué
parallèlement au traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle
et je voudrais
au-delà de ces initiatives que vous
faites vivre
saluer la première promotion ici
présente du programme génération Europe
portée par l'Office Franco-Allemand pour
la Jeunesse illustration concrète de
cette ambition au cœur de notre été de
l'Elysée et d'Aix-la-Chapelle de
compréhension mutuelle entre nos peuples
et d'ambition que vous aurez apporté
aujourd'hui et demain
mesdames et messieurs et Monsieur le
Chancelier vient de le dire parfaitement
chez Olaf
centièmes anniversaire à une
signification particulière au moment où
l'Ukraine résiste à l'agression de la
Russie où l'idéal de paix de dialogue a
été bafoué où l'espoir même d'un ordre
humaniste en Europe et menacé et où les
dérèglements du monde
bouscule tant de certitudes dans nos
pays
face à ces périls
il nous faut plus que jamais
porter l'idéal d'une Europe plus unie et
pleinement maîtresse de son destin
oui
cette Europe que nous avons défendue
l'un l'autre en septembre 2017 sous
cette même coupole
et vous-même Monsieur le Chancelier en
août 2022 à l'université Charles de
Prague dans cette autre temple des
valeurs humanistes de notre Europe
ce projet de renforcement de la
souveraineté européenne
a pris la force d'une nécessité et d'une
évidence pour tous
à présent l'Allemagne et la France
partage la responsabilité de le faire
advenir dans tous les domaines avec leur
partenaire au sein de l'Union européenne
nous avons su le faire face à la
pandémie par une relance économique qui
nous a permis une capacité
d'investissement
inédite à 27 et la mutualisation de
dette commune pour des investissements à
venir impensable quelques mois plus tôt
nous l'avons décidé ensemble Allemagne
et France quelques semaines après le
début de la pandémie pour que cela
puisse advenir des juillet 2020
nous le faisons jour après jour pour la
défense de l'Ukraine
après le 24 février notre union ne s'est
ni divisée
ni dérobé à ses responsabilités
et notre soutien un défectible aux côtés
du peuple ukrainien se poursuivra dans
tous les domaines
nous avons soutenu l'Ukraine sanctionner
la Russie et ensemble sommes allés à
Kiev pour ouvrir là aussi un chemin que
quelques semaines plus tard notre Europe
a consacré et nous continuerons à
soutenir le choix clair fait par le
Conseil européen de donner à l'Ukraine
comme à la Moldavie le statut de
candidat et nous continuerons à les
accompagner ainsi que les autres pays
candidats des Balkans occidentaux sur le
chemin des réformes nécessaires
cette responsabilité de l'Allemagne et
de la France est aussi de renforcer la
cohésion de l'ensemble de la famille
européenne à travers la communauté
politique européenne et je vous remercie
Monsieur le Chancelier du soutien que
vous avez apporté à ce projet fédérateur
à l'échelle du continent
nous avons aussi su prendre les
décisions qui s'imposaient pour
nous-mêmes pour la réduction de nos
dépendances stratégiques pour une Europe
plus forte et souveraine en matière
énergétique technologique militaire
industriel alimentaire
c'est l'agenda que nous avons dessiné
ensemble en Europe 1 à Versailles en
mars dernier
et grâce à ses décisions d'ores et déjà
notre union n'est plus la même
et les choix fait ces derniers mois
en matière de défense en matière
énergétique par nos deux pays
[Musique]
sont des choix historiques qui nous
permettront de continuer d'avancer et
d'aller plus loin
mais le travail qui reste à accomplir
est immense pour atteindre notre
objectif d'une Europe plus souveraine
plus démocratique et plus solidaire
et cela
ne dépend presque que de nous Européens
de nos choix des décisions que nous
prenons et de celles que nous ne prenons
pas
alors comme nos deux pays ont su le
faire à chaque tournant de la
construction européenne
et non que ce fut facile bien au
contraire
l'Allemagne et la France feront le choix
de l'avenir
vous l'avez parfaitement dit chez la fin
l'instant
le couple franco-allemand
est un couple pour lequel rien n'était
écrit
et si tout était simple ce couple
n'aurait ni être célébré ni à
constamment serait inventé
il est grand
quand il arrive en quelque sorte à
bousculer la fatalité
à revisiter les intérêts d'un côté
l'autre du Rhin et à bâtir un chemin
plus grand
que ce qui le compose
celui d'une unité
d'une fusion entre nos peuples nos
histoires pour rendre notre Europe plus
forte c'est ce choix d'avenir
qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
et l'Allemagne et la France parce
qu'elles ont défricher le chemin de la
réconciliation doivent devenir pionnière
pour la refondation de notre Europe
ensemble
pionnière d'abord pour bâtir ensemble un
nouveau modèle énergétique par-delà nos
différences
nous devons encourager et accélérer au
niveau européen les investissements
publics et privés nécessaires à la
transition écologique nous devons
achever la diversification de nos
sources et voie d'approvisionnement et
encourager la production d'énergie
décarbonée sur notre continent
pionnière ensuite pour l'innovation et
les technologies de demain pour bâtir la
prospérité
l'avenir écologique et le modèle social
qui nous unit
cela passe par l'accélération de nos
convergences la simplification de nos
règles cela passe par une stratégie
industrielle européenne ambitieuse qui
assure la résilience de la production
sur le sol européen par une stratégie
made in Europe 2030 comme nous l'avons
l'un l'autre poussé pour faire de notre
continent le champion de ces nouvelles
technologies et de l'intelligence
artificielle
pionnière ensemble pour une Union
européenne capable de s'assumer comme
puissance géopolitique à part entière en
matière de défense en matière spatiale
en matière diplomatique
pionnière en fin pour une union plus
efficace plus protectrice et qui défend
ses valeurs
car au fond notre objectif de
souveraineté c'est s'assurer de tenir
notre destin entre nos mains
nous devons le mettre au profit de nos
valeurs communes de notre modèle
européen qui repose sur notre humanisme
notre attachement à la liberté et à la
solidarité
alors achevons ensemble d'en faire en
l'espace d'une génération
un espace de solidarité de liberté celle
de penser de créer de voyager
d'entreprendre d'innover de rêver
cette robe pour laquelle ensemble
Allemagne et France seront pionnières et
celles des universités de la musique de
la littérature de la création des
théâtres de la culture
cette Europe c'est celle qu'ensemble
nous voulons refonder
est allé notre ligne d'horizon en ce
jour de célébration
où nous réunirons le 23ème Conseil des
ministres franco-allemand
chers amis
l'itinéraire de fraternité que nos deux
peuples ont subâtir après s'être tant
déchirée nous oblige
le traité de l'Élysée et l'aventure
européenne
était des pas inouïe
que tout des habitudes
et des facilités pouvaient empêcher
et c'est pourquoi à mes yeux
ce jour ne doit pas simplement être
celui d'une célébration mais d'une
promesse d'un engagement d'un appel
d'une ambition nouvelle
à l'heure où l'histoire semble sortir à
nouveau de ses gonds trouvons le ressort
d'être à la hauteur de l'espoir que tous
ceux qui nous ont précédés avaient placé
en nous
affrontons les périls du temps avec cet
héritage de courage et d'imagination
avec ce devoir de fidélité à l'audace
avec l'assurance que tout est possible
si l'on demeure unique
et oui c'est les branches ensemble
aujourd'hui avec vous mesdames les
présidentes Messieurs les Présidents et
nos représentants des assemblées comme
nos ministres cet itinéraire fraternel à
la Sorbonne c'est que nous voulons bâtir
une ambition nouvelle
ici
dans ce lieu de savoir ici
à la Sorbonne dans cet université qui
porte le nom de son fondateur et celui
d'un village des Ardennes dont les
paysages ont vu les cendres de la guerre
entre nos donations
dans ce lieu de culture et de savoir où
passèrent des érudits de toute l'Europe
de Thomas d'Aquin Albert de Cologne et
qui inventèrent l'esprit universaliste
du continent ici dans ce lieu où on a
toujours rêvé tout à la fois le
patriotisme comme l'aventure européenne
comme étant aussi un appel à l'universel
ici
ou par le savoir
l'apprentissage la compréhension
les arts on a toujours voulu bâtir
l'amour de ce que nous sommes nos
héritages
à travers quelque chose de plus grand
que nous
et dans cette faculté qui honora erns
Robert cursus un Allemand pleinement
européen et qui voit la cent ans
ne voulait pas se résoudre à éteindre
son amour pour la littérature française
Man a écrit des pages sublimes pour
qualifier l'amitié entre cursus et Gide
il a écrit qu'ils étaient deux âmes dans
une même poitrine
voilà une autre image de la complicité
morale de la fraternité de destin de ce
que nous sommes deux
âmes dans une même poitrine
elle ne se ressemblent pas elles n'ont
pas la même histoire
mais elles sont dans cette même poitrine
et elle bat à l'unisson deux
âmes dans une même poitrine c'est nous
alors sachez toutes et tous ici
aujourd'hui
pouvoir compter sur notre détermination
ensemble à continuer à faire de l'amitié
entre l'Allemagne et la France l'un des
arbres de vie de la souveraineté
européenne sachez que l'un l'autre nous
continuerons de faire avancer ce couple
jadis impossible
qui est le fruit simplement de la
volonté du courage et de la force
et nous le ferons ensemble pour qu'à
votre tour vous
vous puissiez célébrer cette part
d'histoire mais surtout continuer de
bâtir la vôtre en ayant tous les choix
et la liberté en particulier de choisir
votre avenir c'est notre responsabilité
pour vous
vive l'amitié entre l'Allemagne et la
France et vive notre Europe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la nettoie son nom et voilà donc pour
les deux îles l'hymne allemand la
Marseillaise
sur cet estrade du grand amphithéâtre de
la Sorbonne
dans quelques minutes l'hymne à la joie
l'hymne européen bien évidemment on va
revenir avec nos invités
sur les deux discours du chancelier
allemand du président français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
l'assistante debout les applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
vous le reconnaissez l'hymne à la joie
l'hymne européen
[Musique]
dans cette grande salle Richelieu de la
Sorbonne
des membres du gouvernement allemand le
gouvernement français
des étudiants français allemands
et bien évidemment des parlementaires
députés français députés allemands
et les deux présidentes des deux
assemblées nationales et vous la voyez
et pour le Bundes qui encadre de
chancelier allemand et de président
français
[Musique]
et voilà donc pour tes dîmes et c'est de
discours et la poignée de main vous le
voyez chaleureuse appuyé entre deux
chanceliers scholls et le président
français toujours en plateau avec moi
pour recommencer ces deux discours en
école miseauto de l'Institut Jacques
Delors Richard Verly du quotidien suisse
biblique Joseph devec de la revenue
allemande rappelez-moi son nom
diplomates allemands pas d'annonce
concrètes majeures pour ceux qui
attendaient une feuille de route dans le
contexte de guerre en Ukraine mais des
mots des symboles et très appuyé cette
amitié indéfectible franco-allemande
dans la bouche des deux dirigeants en
économie auto oui alors d'abord moi je
voudrais dire je trouve ça très émouvant
on n'est pas dans la Sorbonne mais
j'imagine que dans la Sorbonne il doit y
avoir quand même une espèce de communion
notamment avec ces trois Hymes de
magnifiquement interprétées
donc je crois que c'était très important
d'une part au niveau de l'émotion
d'autre part les deux chefs d'État ont
pris le registre de l'émotion
olafals en parlant de l'affection
fraternelle entre les deux peuples en
parlant de de des frérots nature des
frères et soeurs français en disant que
oui que le le le franco-allemand était
une seconde nature et et Emmanuel Macron
par ayant cette phrase extraordinaire
deux âmes dans une même poitrine et donc
les deux ont choisi un registre
émotionnel je crois très puissant et
alors aussi très ancrée dans l'histoire
et c'est peut-être un peu voilà le
moment ma seule critique très entrée
dans l'histoire l'histoire séculaire pas
simplement les deux précédentes guerre
mondiale l'histoire séculaire de
l'Europe pour justifier la grandeur le
courage de ce couple franco-allemand et
ils n'ont pas je pense à mon à mes yeux
assez démontré
que l'avenir un certain dans lequel nous
allons rentrer est nécessite autant à
autant de de comment dire nécessite
autant le maintien de ce couple
franco-allemand de cette amitié
franco-allemande que ne le faisait
d'histoire je crois qu'ils ont été
vraiment très centrés sur les riches
d'historiques alors et enfin dernier
point ils ont montré que la crise
franco-allemande comme on en a parlé ces
derniers temps était une crise technique
bien sûr mais ne remettez absolument pas
en cause l'importance la profondeur et
la sincérité je crois qu'il y avait
quelque chose de très sincère dans les
deux hommes de l'amitié franco-allemande
ouais amitié indestructible on le
comprend à la fois parce qu'elle est
elle existe depuis longtemps et parce
qu'elle a l'avenir devant elle on va
réécouter ce qu'elle dit Olaf Scholl son
attendait énormément de choses sur la
guerre en Ukraine à un moment où
beaucoup de pays européens et évidemment
l'Ukraine en premier lieu demande à
l'Allemagne et à la France la livraison
de charlour soutient militaire à
l'Ukraine mais pas plus de précision
écoutez chancelier allemand
la guerre d'agression russe contre
l'Ukraine à brutalement mi fin à se
consensus établit à l'échelle du
continent
le président Vladimir Poutine a divisé
impérialiste il cherche à déplacer les
frontières par la force les Ukrainiennes
et les Ukrainiens en paix le prix
terrible
mais l'impérialisme de Vladimir Poutine
ne vaincra pas
nous nous serons ceux qui au côté de nos
voisins et partenaires écriront les
prochains chapitres de l'histoire
européenne et nous on ne laisserons pas
le rapport
où la violence remplacer la politique et
où la haine et les rivalités nationales
déchiraient notre continent
en témoigne notamment nos décisions
prises ces derniers jours
on nettoie
de alukraine de véhicules blindés de
combat d'infanterie et de reconnaissance
nous continuerons de fournir l'Ukraine
aussi longtemps que nécessaire tout le
soutien dont elle aura besoin pour
défendre notre projet de paix européen
voilà Joachim betterlich quel est votre
réaction le chancelier allemand est-il
allé assez loin dans le soutien à
l'Ukraine on attendait une clarification
notamment sur les chars lourds
la Sorbonne n'était pas les lieux pour
de telles annonces ça je vous dis en
toute franchise je pense les deux
Emmanuel Macron comme olafolls on fait
dit ce que j'appelle le nécessaire dans
cette enceinte les deux pays au service
de l'Europe unie pionniers pour la
refondation de l'Europe et ensuite
évidemment ce que Nicole a mentionné
c'est symbolisme assez fort la
complicité franco-allemande à la fin je
pense c'était pas ici d'aller plus loin
ou si tactiquement et moi je trouve deux
discours je le trouve très bien
entièrement à la hauteur et elle m'a
surtout Emmanuel Macron a mentionné
davantage les domaines sur lesquels les
deux pays vont se concentrer à l'avenir
je pense très clair et où la chose a
fait ajouter sa part il y a eu quelque
part une réconciliation entre les
discours ce que j'appelle de la Sorbonne
et de Prague
vous voyez les choses ainsi Richard
Verlaine paradoxalement je trouve que le
discours du chancelier a été plus
politique que celui de d'Emmanuel Macron
politique dans deux directions d'abord
on sent que c'était un discours pour
rassurer la France et les Français il
s'est à plusieurs reprises tourner vers
la France il employait les mots
fraternels affections indestructibles et
il y avait des raisons de faire ce
discours parce que on a mis en doute la
volonté de la folz d'être encore le
l'artisan de ce couple franco-allemand
donc premier élément très politique
envers les français pour que les
Français aient confiance dans
l'Allemagne deuxième élément très
politique aussi en ce sens que Olaf
Scholtz est resté sur le concret il n'a
pas eu d'envoler lyrics et c'est là où
je voulais en venir Emmanuel Macron
beaucoup plus lyrique lit au fond
Emmanuel Macron a tiré les conséquences
littéraires d'être à la Sorbonne avec
l'éloge du savoir avec la référence
personnalité comme naturel etc dans le
cas de la Scholl c'était vraiment et là
Joachim Billy je l'a dit un complément à
destination des Français de son discours
de Prague voilà je crois que il faut
bien pour Olaf Scholl c'était l'heure
des clarifications pour Emmanuel Macron
il est dans l'élan alors est-ce que la
référence au char léopard puisque c'est
de s'accompare elle n'avait pas lieu
d'être à la Sorbonne peut-être on notera
quand même qu'il a parlé de blinder il a
parlé de de blindé de combat à partir du
moment où vous dites véhicules de combat
vous englobez quand même beaucoup de
choses donc au fond ce qu'on retient
c'est l'affirmation de l'Allemagne
qu'elle ne va pas se dérober en matière
de soutien militaire à l'Ukraine Joseph
deck il y avait
une forme comment dire quoi d'ambiguïté
organisée dans cette phrase importante
attendue sur la question militaire en
Ukraine l'Allemagne s'engage sans dire
véritablement jusqu'où oui je pense je
suis d'accord avec Monsieur bettalis
c'est pas le livre c'était pas l'endroit
ici un public français sur le sol
français c'était pas l'endroit et je
pense le message le plus important est
vraiment que l'Allemagne tient à cette
relation franco-allemande elle qu'elle
se réinvestisse sur cette question et
pour Scholtz ou pour un discours d'un
chantier allemand il était extrêmement
émotionnel il était très lyrique en
réalité alors ça c'est peut-être une
différence si on écoute normalement les
discours de chaudes c'est beaucoup plus
neutre beaucoup plus sobre là il a parlé
d'émotion il a parlé de fraternité il a
parlé de cœur
il a il a dit que la France est
indispensable il a dit que la France
était un grand peuple il a vraiment pour
un discours d'un chantier allemand il
est allé très très loin dans l'émotion
et je pense je suis d'accord avec
Monsieur bitalier et j'avais dit il
voulait vraiment rassurer les Français
et dire nous on est là ensemble vous
êtes le partenariat indispensable pour
vous oui pour moi c'est vraiment je
pense il y a je pense il y a une prise
de conscience de choses que que qu'il
fallait pas que cette relation reste
importante et qu'on peut pas faire sans
et là il a vraiment il est allé à 200
km/h pour pour
la clarification sur l'évidence pour
reprendre le terme du chancelier
l'évidence de l'amitié du couple
franco-allemand alors peut-être que il
va se décider des choses cet après-midi
à l'Elysée Marco pommier il y a un
conseil des ministres franco-allemand un
fameux conseil qui n'avait pas pu avoir
lieu il avait été reporté cette fois
c'est fail aura lieu cet après-midi
quelle est la suite du programme
oui Myriam olive et Emmanuel Macron vont
maintenant se retrouver à l'Elysée pour
un déjeuner de travail et surtout le
ventre pour le 23e Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand il le président cet
après-midi à partir de 13h 13h30 autour
de nombreux ministres allemands et
français au programme et bien il y aura
une réunion de travail par exemple sur
la politique industrielle la
présentation également de projets
industriels franco-allemand et même un
conseil de défense et de sécurité les
deux hommes qui échangeront également
avec des jeunes avec la première
promotion du programme génération Europe
jeune talent ola schols et Emmanuel
Macron enfin qui donneront une
conférence de presse conjointe aux
alentours de 17h et puis il dîneront ce
soir en privé à l'Élysée merci beaucoup
Marco pommier Nicole mesotos c'est
peut-être cet après-midi qu'il peut se
décider ou se dessiner des politiques
communes pour français ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'effectivement
chaque fois qu'il y a un grandes réunion
franco-allemande on attend une décision
une initiative ce qui prouve à quel
point ce couple est effectivement un
moteur et je suis sûr que toutes nos
partenaires européens dans leurs
différentes capitales attendent de voir
ce qu'ils vont annoncer alors peut-être
qu'ils vont annoncer quelque chose
peut-être pas moi je trouve que
l'événement en tant que tel est un
événement c'est-à-dire il n'y a pas de
crise
franco-allemande décisive non déplaise à
ce que disent parfois les Polonais et
d'autres pays de l'Est ou d'Europe
centrale qui accuse le couple
franco-allemand d'abord d'être
maintenant un peu préhistorique
correspondant à Varsovie on considère
que les équilibres ont changé et que le
moteur franco-allemand est cassé
qu'est-ce que vous répondez je pense que
non d'ailleurs je trouve que le sens se
lier chose a eu une phrase extrêmement
il y a eu beaucoup de non-dits dans ces
discours mais il y en a eu une du côté
allemand qui était de dire nous
défendons notre à l'intérieur comme
contre l'extérieur et à l'intérieur il a
beaucoup insisté sur l'état de droit la
démocratie etc ce qui est à mon avis une
pique à l'égarder polonais qui se
développe qui défendent la démocratie à
l'extérieur contre le Poutine mais qu'il
a détruise à l'intérieur par leur régime
autoritaire et anti-démocratique et donc
je trouve que c'était bien fait bien dit
et il y a eu d'autres d'autres non-dits
par exemple d'autres ambiguïtés quand
Emmanuel Macron dit nous ferons l'avenir
parce que nous déciderons et par les
décisions que nous ne prenons pas je
pense que là c'était pas du tout une
pique à l'Allemagne contrairement à ce
que pense peut-être les Polonais je
pense que collectivement la décision de
livrer ou pas des chars de combat de
d'aller un cran au-delà dans
l'identification l'intensification de
l'aide militaire est une décision
collective et ça n'est pas simplement la
décision de livrer ou par chercheurs
c'est quelle est notre stratégie quelle
est la fin de la guerre que nous voulons
si on pense que livrer des chars nous
assure la victoire en leur faisons-le
tout de suite qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez que livrer des chats est-ce que
est-ce que c'est une maladie
est-ce que les voilà les tentatives un
peu désespérées de négociation n'ont pas
prouvé que de toute façon il y a rien à
tirer du côté de Poutine aujourd'hui et
que seule la force et l'argument qu'il
peut comprendre si on s'intéresse aux
non-dit il y a quand même quelque chose
que personne ni l'un ni l'autre n'a
abordé c'est la diplomatie et l'espoir
d'une solution diplomatique avec
l'Ukraine on aurait pu penser que ça
aurait trouvé place à la Sorbonne encore
une fois le symbole ce symbole là le
symbole au fond de la main tendue à la
diplomatie il est absent des deux
discours donc ça veut quand même dire
que on a conscience que pour l'instant
l'heure est aux armes qui vont continuer
de parler à priori avec la proximité du
24 février du premier anniversaire du
conflit
une autre chose les victoires
symboliques Emmanuel Macron a marqué une
aujourd'hui c'est le terme de
souveraineté européenne repris par le
chancelier allemand ça souveraineté
européenne devient un terme que Macron
dont Macron peut affirmer qu'il a eu la
paternité et qui est désormais dans le
discours franco-allemand c'est assez
notable Joachim biterly je vous qui êtes
diplomate est-ce que vous acquiez c'est
à l'analyse de Richard Werly au fond pas
d'allusion à une forme de de solution
diplomatique de négociation potentielle
tout ça c'est du passé aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas je me dis ça franchement
est-ce que c'était l'intention de ne pas
en parler est-ce que c'est pas la place
pour en parler est-ce que les deux ont
appris par les réactions des uns et des
autres sur leurs initiatives ce que
j'appelle les coups de téléphone
régulier est-ce qu'il est-ce que c'est
compréhensible pour cela moi je suis je
suis étonné par une avancée assez forte
c'est la souveraineté européenne et
riche admiri a raison parce que au fond
l'allemand mon origine c'est l'Allemagne
et l'allemand est assez
réticent d'utiliser le terme
souveraineté européenne pour des raisons
constitutionnelles pour ça bouge préfère
l'expression de la l'autonomie
stratégique mais là assez fort que comme
idée qu'on pensait et comprenez la
Sorbonne
emploi cette expression qu'est-ce qu'il
met derrière vraiment souveraineté
européenne ça veut dire que il est
d'accord pour s'engager sur des projets
industriels
franco-allemand où ça veut dire qu'il
parle de la défense
il utilise de manière politique et
politique ça veut dire d'un côté la
défense ça veut dire aussi de l'autre
côté des investissements pour le comme
pour le futur commun réduire la
dépendance d'autres il y a tous les
termes qui se réunissent là c'est pas
c'est non seulement la défense c'est
également
une certaine autonomie industrielle pour
le futur de l'Europe
vous vous voyez aussi voilà derrière ces
expressions choisies la potentialité de
projets industriels communs on parle des
batteries électriques on a une
maintenant une nouvelle usine qui va
chercher du lithium dont on dépend avec
la Chine en France est-ce que on peut
s'imaginer que le couple franco-allemand
va s'engager sur des projets industriels
pour gagner en indépendance oui je pense
c'est c'est là le domaine où il y a le
plus de possibilités de d'avoir une
vraie coopération tournée vers l'avenir
vraiment il y a cette idée de
souveraineté européenne cela défense il
y a des urgences d'aujourd'hui on a
besoin les Américains les Allemands ils
ont besoin d'acheter américain pour
leurs besoins d'aujourd'hui mais sur
l'économie on peut agir aujourd'hui et
ce qu'on va voir plus tard dans la
journée avec avec le conseil et après la
conférence de presse j'attends vraiment
voilà qu'est-ce que vous poseriez vous
comme question de dirigeant vous les
oreillez en face de vous à la conférence
de presse
alors je pense la grande question qui se
pose c'est jusqu'à présent à la crise ou
à la guerre en Ukraine on n'a pas encore
vraiment eu une réponse économique
européenne commune pour pour gérer les
conséquences de cette guerre et de la
reconstruction vous parlez de militaire
oui
elle doit être financée et de les
Européens ils doivent être en charge de
ça dans une large partie mais aussi il y
a tout autre question les conséquences
économiques de la crise d'énergie après
la politique industrielle sur ces
questions là il se posent la question
comment est-ce qu'on finança et est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce que l'Europe a un rôle
a joué de là dedans et jusqu'à présent
ça c'est le grand absent et surtout si
on compare à la pandémie là il y avait
une réponse européenne aussi au niveau
économique et je pense à un accent fort
qui pourrait mettre et de dire qu'ils
veulent aller dans ce sens là
j'aurai deux questions la première
anecdotique pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
n'a-t-il pas prononcé la moindre phrase
en allemand alors que le chancelier
schols l'a fait en disant si j'ai bien
noté merci de tout cœur merci pour votre
amitié et il a dit en français donc
pourquoi ce choix de faire un discours
intégralement en français ça serait la
première question la deuxième question
elle porte sur quand même l'Ukraine et
c'est à dire est-ce que véritablement
quelle Europe à quoi ressemblera
l'Europe vu du couple franco-allemand
cette Europe qui dans le futur intégrera
l'Ukraine parce que là à partir du
moment où on projette le couple
franco-allemand dans l'avenir et bien il
faut qu'il soit pilote pilote de quelle
Europe là la question reste posée et
vous n'y connaissez moi ce qui m'a
frappé d'abord c'est qu'ils n'ont
absolument au-delà de la diplomatie
éventuelle sur la guerre en Ukraine ils
n'ont absolument pas parlé de la
politique étrangère c'est-à-dire du rôle
de l'Union européenne dans le monde
comme si tous les deux soient renoncés à
faire de l'Europe un acteur politique
soit au contraire
préserver ça pour peut-être plus tard
peut-être il y aura une annonce est-ce
que c'est pas typiquement français ça de
jouer la carte diplomatique en disant
l'Europe doit peser est-ce que
l'Allemagne est vraiment habité par
cette question là
je crois que dans son discours après le
chancelier avait parlé de l'avenir et du
rôle de l'Union européenne donc je
trouve moi la question que je leur
poserai mais comment allez-vous vendre
entre guillemets aux jeunes générations
aux gens qui doivent s'impliquer dans
l'Europe qu'est-ce que vous allez leur
dire les amener à soutenir l'Europe quel
rôle l'Union peut jouer pour pacifier ce
monde Joachim betterlich géant mémoire
le discours de Joe Biden juste après son
élection le président américain avait
invité au fond les Européens dans une
grande alliance des démocraties contre
la Chine et la Russie
voulant englober l'Europe d'une certaine
manière dans cette alliance avec les
États-Unis c'est vrai qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à une réponse à cette
question là vous pensez que l'Europe
franco-allemande veut peser
diplomatiquement sur l'ordre mondial
aujourd'hui c'est une étape je pense il
y a des domaines ou français allemands
devront concrétiser leur point de vue et
un de ces domaines en effet Nicole
entièrement raison le grand absent de ce
discours c'est le rôle de l'Europe dans
le monde sinon on veut et là évidemment
des réponses à chercher mais laissons à
ce couple le temps les mois venir pour
avancer et pour présenter des idées
concrètes peut-être même le moment sur
une paix en Ukraine on va terminer avec
l'émotion justement que vous soulignez
tous les trois tous les quatre on va
réécouter Yaël Braun Pivet qui a pris la
parole la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale au tout début de ces de ces
discours avec cette confession
personnelle
si j'évoque ici le souvenir de Rosa ma
grand-mère né allemande
épouse d'un réfugié polonais tous deux
naturalisé français c'est pour vous dire
simplement
que du plus loin tant de mon enfance la
Présidence de l'Assemblée nationale que
je suis devenue à entendu des moines
pour exprimer l'amour d'une vieille dame
à sa petite fille
et l'espoir d'une vie heureuse en Europe
quel serait fière et émue de nous voir
aujourd'hui
tenant cette promesse devenue réalité
tangible
cela grâce à l'esprit de responsabilité
qui a su prévaloir des deux côtés du
Rhin
voilà c'est aussi ça l'Europe des
petites histoires dans la grande
histoire elle a fait preuve d'émotion
c'était c'était frappant absolument et
c'est le fait en plus que qui est un
nouvel venu en politique c'est pas un
pays c'est pas un visage que l'on
connaissait depuis longtemps donc il y a
là peut-être l'incarnation d'un
renouveau d'un renouveau ancré dans
l'histoire elle l'a fait de manière très
personnelle donc à la fois c'était
sincère et c'est bien joué politiquement
merci on va s'arrêter là merci beaucoup
merci Joakim biterlich d'avoir été à
distance merci pour vos analyses
pertinentes à tous les trois rendez-vous
à 14h30 sur LCP pour la suite du
programme il va se jouer ici même au
Palais Bourbon avec une sorte immense
séance de questions au Gouvernement
franco-allemand vous aurez des ministres
Allemands et des ministres français aux
banques avec les parlementaires français
et allemands pour les interpeller les
interroger pendant plus d'une heure et
puis ensuite un échange avec avec la
jeunesse on va suivre ça tout cet
après-midi 14h30 sur LCP merci à vous
merci à Valérie Brochard merci également
à Marco pommier et merci infiniment à
toutes les équipes techniques pour cette
belle matinée de direct franco-allemande
sur LCP à tout à l'heure 14h30
[Musique]